oh [ __ ] the church of what's happening
now is brought to you by onit.com
go to on it for the finest supplements
in the business
from shroom tech sport
to shroom tech immune
to alpha brain to the hem force protein
i love and use everything go to
honor.com right now and press in church
bam and get 10 off delivered right to
your home they also have kettlebells and
whatnot i can't help you with those
supplements i'm the man to see go to
honor.com and press in church bam number
two the days are back the summer's
coming
swamp ass is your friend in the summer
if you live on the east coast st louis
florida by the time you get home your
ass is sweating it sweats right through
your [ __ ] underwear to the middle of
your ass you got to go home you're
embarrassed but listen there's no reason
to walk around with a stinky [ __ ] you
know why
because like i said bidets are back
hellotushi.com
go to hellotushi.com and press in church
boom and get 10 off
your first order you understand me one
of the best products out there
60 90 day guarantee it don't matter i'll
take that [ __ ] ass of yours and scrub
it clean
hit it lead
out of respect [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now
lee syed
one of my new favorite people in the
world mr louis gomez what's up baby
kick this mule lee
bong hits
hugs whatever the [ __ ] you need
it's the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
thursday the 25th you bad [ __ ]
memorial day weekend the church
are you kidding me or what you bad
[ __ ]
thank you very much for listening to the
church of what's happening now louis
gomez lee syed
we're here we're queer we opened up an
audio slave out of respect uh
rest in peace tomorrow they're gonna
bury chris cornell right down the corner
here so
uh who the [ __ ] knows today i was just
[ __ ] around and i had the earphones
on and i just put on one of the old
uh i put on slaves and bulldozers and if
you leave youtube on and working on
something else on the computer just
keeps playing songs
and this one came up and i went to the
video and i just [ __ ] started crying
it was over yeah you bet you're a big
chris cornell fan yeah yeah yeah big
sound garden fan you know i lived in
seattle
they were like a third of the reason why
i moved up there i was like how the [ __ ]
are these people even all these bands in
one place this is
it was too much you know yeah i got to
see him up there one time
and uh i never i don't want to see him
again my friend davillo invited me when
they went to the 20th year of union of
super unknown at uh
where you guys hang out what's the place
upstairs they do concerts there
somebody shot a special in new york city
oh uh
gramercy
factory no downtown somewhere i forget
the [ __ ]
name of it oh
where big j did his right yeah what's
the name of that webster hall yes
website i think it was webster hall so
you know i always missed out but i got
to see him and
before they broke up and uh
it's just weird how
you never understand how people could be
like come to your shows
like you know how you guys have people
that come to your shows yeah
and they'll pull you aside and they go
hey man i really like what you're doing
on skank
you know legion's a skank it really
makes my week or whatever and they walk
away
and in the back of your mind you're
gonna get something [ __ ] guys crazy
like what the [ __ ] he talking about
right
but then today when chris cornell came
on you know uh cassius morris
had some thing the other night and he
goes write like a song that
maybe you relate to like this old like
sabbath bloody sabbath when i was
15 and out there running and gunning and
my mom was dead and i had horrible
[ __ ] thoughts
that song fueled me i don't know why
till this day if i want to get fired up
i listen to sad bloody sabbath you're
going to get stabbed yeah like i don't
even put it in the car because i lose my
mind and i do 90. yeah that's the cool
that's the the really cool thing about
music is that's what it is it
whatever you're doing there's a song or
a type of music
that you can kind of add to you can add
a soundtrack to it like in your life
like if you're working out i think
that's why i think on pandora they
should add like a what you're doing
option right so if i'm working out if
i'm lifting weights right that's a it's
different if i want to listen to nine
inch nails there's a different nine inch
nails for working out
than there is for
you know hanging out with my chick in in
a room [ __ ] you know about to have
sex or whatever it is i don't know who
has sex in 90 snails i was going to say
you do everything
yeah i'm nine inch nailing her
i wish like i have not five and a half
inch music and forty five i never did
that i never understood when i was a kid
i did it i did it till like 18 and then
i was like what the [ __ ] you don't have
sexy music yeah
i don't [ __ ] i do it let's not come
in a minute
by the time i [ __ ] come if i got two
minutes to listen to this terrible song
i'm listening to you that's why this is
why you're coming in a minute because
you're focusing too much on the [ __ ] if
you're focusing on the music
you might be able to [ __ ] go you know
30 40 minutes boom you know lewis gomez
you're a [ __ ] unadulterated genius
from time to time
i gotta hand it to you i've heard that
you're the last of the real mohicans
we
how old were you when they blew up
oklahoma both of these oklahoma city
what year was that the 94 yeah i was six
maybe five depending on the twelve 12.
i was 12 years old yeah wow i bought
this uh
i got stuck i was buying coke from this
mexican that called into the podcast
very in the beginning do you remember
that lee was my roommate at the halfway
house right the uh
hispanic dude yeah real cool i loved
alex with all my huh it wasn't alex's
book
at that time if ounces of coke were like
800 bucks alex was getting me out it's
just a four from some mexican cartel
yeah he was in prison with
and the coke was always [ __ ]
tremendous like [ __ ] people call me
back no where the [ __ ] did you get that
like i was thinking of a coke hang over
the other day and i go to one monday
when i did like two grams of that stuff
and the next morning i was riding a
bicycle
to this place called the delhi zone in
boulder when it was on the valmont
and i'll never forget that i was like
jesus christ
i could feel the electricity in my body
from the blow like i was that hung over
on the coke you know
i was getting some great coke from him
and one time i bought this coke that was
really [ __ ] strong
so i just kept going cut on it but i ran
out of a regular cut
i started throwing vitamins in there
like some type of vitamin
then the [ __ ] kid came and he got a
dui so i got stuck with the coke
and it was the same week that they blew
up
that [ __ ] tower and i had you know
how people put
black under their eyes
to block the sun when they play football
yeah i had two scabs
under my nose from the vitamins wow
that's how [ __ ] down i was in 94 and
i'm sitting in this apartment
i'm watching this [ __ ] uh
stupid uh coverage on this [ __ ]
idiot these two idiots that bombed this
[ __ ] daycare center in oklahoma
i'm basically [ __ ] broke i want
i can't describe to you two guys how
badly i wanted to be a comedian at that
time
and i was going up every night you know
i was living in denver how many options
i had compared to you louis gomez not
many
i would always had to go to a poetry
reading or i would have to drive to
loveland colorado so here i am it's two
in the afternoon i'm [ __ ] frustrated
with my life
and on top of all this louis gomez my
[ __ ] ex-wife is [ __ ] around with
me with this child
the kid's four years old and i'm having
a hard time with it every time i call
the attorney it's costing me four
hundred dollars
i can't tell you the part in my life how
[ __ ] frustrated i am at this point
and i look at this [ __ ] screen on the
tv and i see these towers and i see
these people crying and
i take the [ __ ] remote control i'm
scrolling
and mtv comes on
and it's these [ __ ] dudes
who are like doing something with their
instruments
and all of a sudden the guitar player
walks up
and he starts strumming the guitar and
i'm looking at this like you have to be
watching this like this is like a sign
from god
and the guy starts belting out lyrics
and it was fell on black days
and he was up to maybe
he was singing maybe a minute and i had
tears in my eyes i swallowed up because
it was me
in the beginning he talked something
about uh
you know they reminded me of my daughter
at the time i had all this joy that was
taken away
and fell on black days he talks about
prison but like not prison prison
but like when you're which i'm not i
don't i'm gonna make it sounds super
unknown it's just what song is that
yeah
just go to youtube go to youtube super
unknown no you just go sound garden
fell on black days
and i'll show you the video show me the
computer because i have to
do you want to watch it you want to
watch the video let me just put it up
and i'll show you because this is what
came on this is what came on the tv
and it was just [ __ ] mind-boggling
whatsoever that i feared has come to
life whatsoever
uh something became my life
just when every day
seems to greet me with a smile the first
song up there
it's completely different than the album
though
the album was a studio cut listen to
this all right so right now i switch and
this is what i see
and i'm looking at this guy
and i'm like i gotta watch this right
here
oh yeah that song is a great song i'm
like what the [ __ ]
i'm looking at that [ __ ] japanese
godzilla looking [ __ ] i'm like
to look like that that dude's got to be
able to play kenneth whatever his name
is look at him
yeah it's completely different than the
owl yeah this is like a studio
let's just jam it one time
so funny like rock music was like
a few years where it was really simple
and kind of like basic and kind of it's
just
you almost like because i played in the
band when i was uh
probably from like 15 to like 18
and it's like that was right around that
time it was probably uh like you know
eighth grade to like you know 12th grade
or whatever you know probably around
that time salty black flower was the
name of my band and we were like really
inspired by like you know especially my
singer like you know the grunger nirvana
sound
like to see here's the funny part i
didn't really like grunge
because i grew up on 80s metal like my
sister was a few years older than me so
i was always i would if you have an
older sibling you just like whatever the
[ __ ] they are that's it you know they're
your influence you know so you don't
have an opinion of music when you're
[ __ ] seven you just have whatever's
around and my sister was around
listening to you know poison skid row
motley crew so my first like favorite
music my first two concerts ever were
poison concerts on skinny bop like that
great like i'm a little [ __ ] seven
year old kid nine year old kid
you know
in this metal concert with everyone's
got teased harems the only brown person
there is a little [ __ ] puerto rican
kid
um but
the grunge music kind of killed
the 80s metal
like era like skid row was like my [ __ ]
like to this day i love skid row like
that's like my one of my favorites
saying his name sebastian box
yeah jersey guy oh yeah oh yeah good
looking dude man remember sebastian dude
he came out he was 18. just [ __ ]
gorgeous long hair had like the best
voice his voice was out of control
but
though these guys came out nirvana
soundgarden
uh you know all these guys from seattle
that whole grunge movement it just wiped
it away and then it became almost
comical to look at like the hair metal
guys because these guys looked [ __ ]
cool if you're a chick
you don't want us go and [ __ ]
bret michaels with his dumb teased up
hair and [ __ ] pink lipstick on if
[ __ ] this dude shows up with his you
know band and his badass jeans and he's
just [ __ ] look he's got heroin
probably these guys [ __ ] stink these
guys were on [ __ ] listen it was them
it was mother love bone and the singer
died
and there was a lot of other bands i
don't know but you just got to run with
them pearl jam and allison chains at
that time
pearl jam that first album say what you
want to say whatever the [ __ ] it's
called one whatever it had like ten hits
on ten hits yeah yeah every every single
torture it was torture yeah and this
this came out in 94 this lasted a year
alice in chains [ __ ] dirt
when that came out people were jumping
off windows i held on i didn't like any
any band user's name that i did not like
no and at first what do you think i
liked them i was still stuck on [ __ ]
sabbath and high and dry
yeah but when i saw the video to uh
man in the box
yeah i was like i'm gonna tell you
something these dirty [ __ ] went
into something yeah and then i used to
do comedy at giggles in seattle in the u
district
and there was this hot
hot dirty hippie chick
hot and i used to try to blow mushrooms
exotic mushrooms she had body odor but
under under armour every but she had
everything she [ __ ] no no no i [ __ ]
with a girl with under armour
goomba and i liked that she would tell
me if they needed a feature i would tell
her go in the green room see if they
need a feature next week what's on the
board and she would come out and tell me
i would tip her
but she used to always tell me you know
again
yeah and she goes this or anything else
i go
i'll try you know if i knew i could [ __ ]
i'd try anything you know in that age
you know how crazy i was
and she's like if you want i could take
you up to uh lance daley whatever the
singer was of alice in chains and we
could get high and i'm like
what am i going to go up there to watch
her you know her suckers dick yeah when
she's going to suck a chubby comics dick
or let's stay with these [ __ ] you
know i'm saying like it's a no-brainer
so
i i just didn't want to go anywhere
there were needles and i'd have to get
pushed into it i wouldn't mind doing a
line of heroin if i know you and i come
to your house i'll do a line out
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] ya
we're in manhattan and you go we're
going to meet louis gomez
on [ __ ] uh we're going to meet louis
gomez over by the stand yeah right yeah
i was with you at that point right now
we're in the lower east side and some
skinny white dude comes up to me
he's like i got number two
the pencil no number two heroin like
i got it for 20 bucks i just give him 20
bucks and take it even though i'm not
going to shoot it you just have the
option just to have the option you don't
know you don't know who you're going to
run into that night that might say hey
you have some heroin and i'll take a
little [ __ ] spoon of it i won't even
you won't even know yeah
you won't even know i'm doing it i just
take a little spoon like if it's like a
little bit of paddle like this i'll do
the smallest and you snort it you don't
you never inject it's not there's
nothing really a snort you just put your
finger on and go
and that's it you feel a little dizzy
for a while
but once you grow and it's like eating a
viking it's like eating uh you know what
i'm saying oh if you do it that way yeah
there's none of them no i'm not telling
you i'm coming over your house and i'm
gonna pop a syringe that's crazy that's
not happening that's a little bit a
little bit of heroin on the tip of the
pinky that never hurt nobody oh my god
no it wouldn't it would change your
[ __ ] probably wouldn't you put some
on the head of your dick around the head
of your pinky and you do it in your nose
and you put a little bit on the helmet
by the pee hole
and that that gets nice and red oh
that's yummy your girlfriend will call
her sister and go listen you to come
down here you got to catch this dick and
you better wake mom up
this is the dick people been looking for
it's just big and red and you put a
tattoo of a spider on or some [ __ ] women
will flock to your house to suck that
heroin [ __ ] it's like a submarine
i i've never that's like the one drug
because my mom was a heroin addict yeah
you usually get from a different
perspective i just you know i have an
ex-girlfriend who was a heroin addict
like it's just kind of crazy i would
never it's kind of a scary thing it
almost you know it reminds me of like
like just the the the same danger that i
felt the first time i ever held a gun
you know because if you don't if you
never shot a gun before it's like it's
an intense it's real it's a very
powerful feeling yeah and what you get
used to i think actually i think they
should give like
younger people lessons to know what
they're doing with that just you know
you never know what's going to happen if
you need to handle a gun and you know
for your own safety not even to kill
somebody with it it's not to shoot
yourself in the stomach or shoot your
body because you don't know how to take
it off safety or whatever right
um but that same danger that i i felt
when i've seen people do heroin or i've
seen it around like they'll pull out a
bag or whatever
that same type of danger that i felt the
first time i held a gun
is that and i'm like uh i can't even and
if
none of my friends you know literally
nobody that i know like openly would
just do heroin like i don't but i think
it's a different time in comedy now too
because people don't really openly do
coke the way no they use no no no it is
very bad and i'm very proud of that yeah
i'm very happy that well it's a business
now comedians are not thinking this is
the [ __ ] you know when i came up i
was paying attention to prior and i was
paying attention to kenneth and i liked
the stories yeah that gave me the green
rock and rock like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
than i was with drugs at the store and
[ __ ] like that it gave me the green
light but if somebody came up to me bro
if you're a comic
stick with the [ __ ] reefer you know
man reefer you want a couple beers
else
when you get [ __ ] up the comedy world
knows about it
well that's the other thing is
they um i think because everyone's on
facebook and twitter and everyone it
feels like everything's very naked like
as soon as somebody
whatever it is you know [ __ ] somebody
beat somebody in a roast battle or
somebody gets into an argument in the
comedy scene it just travels very fast
so i feel like people aren't as willing
to
openly come out and go oh yeah i do blow
because even if people aren't going to
go and tweet that or put it on social
media people still kind of feel that
there's a not the same sense of secrecy
that there was you know years ago i saw
comedy almost 13 years ago so even in
that time it just jumped it's a very
open scene and everybody talks well i
i grew up very very in the suburbs so to
me anyone talking about coke is out as
strange to me like it like is
it is imprinted in my brain
but like i
i know people who do coke
i i don't think i probably know somebody
who's done heroin
but i don't i don't know anybody
like but i don't know anybody who like
actively does heroin you know like i
know you've done it joey a couple times
but like you i feel like coke even
though people don't it's not like weed
how how it's all how it's accepted but i
think coke is more accepted than heroin
yeah it's more accepting than harold
none of us accept it anymore not in this
society it's not open you don't go to a
club and somebody goes if you want to
use the bathroom there's a mirror
those days are over with yesterday's
like a long guy i think it is in l.a i
think there's something no i went when i
went to new york and in 93 i was in
shock i went on a date and i went to a
club and i wanted a thing to take a
package out and the guy goes don't even
think about it
mm-hmm don't even [ __ ] think about it
i go bro i used to do i i i was 10 years
ago and i'm like
really yeah no
that's not accepted in new york by any
means kicked out probably five five or
six years ago i got kicked out of a bar
um because i was sitting on a toilet
facing the opposite direction okay like
straddling the toilet
and the guy thought i was doing coke i
was rolling a blunt actually and i was
just happy to be sitting that way but i
guess from his angle you know whatever
it was you know his security guard and
they kicked me out very aggressively did
you ever pants on yeah i had my pants on
okay well imagine if my pants were down
how would a weird position to be sitting
on the toilet nobody straddles it that
way that's what i was gonna i thought i
was gonna i thought that was gonna be
your cover yeah yeah well that was
probably the bad the move when i was
doing coke
i knew
you knew that i was doing code
but because the type of person i was you
weren't going to say nothing to me
i would talk about on stage so you had
nowhere to go with it right
when i when people started telling me
yeah there's a roommate you do come i
said [ __ ] it
i shut these [ __ ] down i'll just be
open well that's how you [ __ ] own it
and that was it anything and nobody ever
really approached me that's brilliant
every once in a while rogan would say
something to me on the plane i would go
drop it bro
don't even talk about it that's my
[ __ ] problem and that was it nobody
ever really
you just assumed well nobody nobody
that's doing coke regularly right is
going like it's not a problem anybody's
doing coca-cola oh no it's a problem
it's a problem it's a problem yeah yeah
it's a problem anything that you're
doing regularly like that is a [ __ ]
problem it already becomes i mean yeah
really any drugs even even weed feeding
weed even though i smoke weed every day
it's a problem it's a problem if i if i
here's when it's not a problem if you
truly don't need to if you can go a few
days i'm like hey i'm going to take a
few days off just to relax you know get
my head straight i'm going to write some
[ __ ] whatever and it's not a thing at
all for you i don't think weed's a
problem but for me to take one day off
even if i had like i was like i'm not
going to smoke weed i got an audition i
really want to focus
that's a big problem i am in a state
where i go if i have an audition i have
to smoke weed so i feel more like myself
you know
and i think that's not good that's like
i liked all that stuff i could go
without like now
i like that i'm a fan of all the things
you just said yeah no no listen you know
many times i've got an audition as
insecure as this
as insecure as it sounds you call me you
go i have an audition
you send me audition i download it i
print the pages it's four pages i look
at the two scenes i'd look at it again
and look at it again now i take those
two pages i put them aside
and i go to my notebook
i put in them you roll it up you smoke
them i write
i write the date of the audition the
time the casting director the director i
even write i even imdb the director and
see what style of movies he's done
before
i do all that work and then i take the
two scenes and i break him down
sober
then i disappear for an hour you know
what i'm saying and you think about
what's going on and then you burn a
[ __ ] good one like you actually go
get a new batch of weed even though you
got a batch there go get a new batch
yeah and you go get that and bring that
home now you smoke it and you start
saying the audition out loud in the room
and you could see the color and then
start acting it out what would you do
when you walk in the room you're just
not going to walk in the room and go
joey wake up you know turn the light on
hit the switch live the [ __ ] whole
thing
because that's when you go to audition
and you [ __ ] them up when you start
flipping switches and bending over yeah
and capturing that's when they're like
oh this [ __ ] thing to work
almost like
it's not even just the weed i think what
that is it's just changing whatever
variable it is right right because i did
this the other day i you know i i did
that roast battle show and i had to
memorize my jokes
and i went in the steam room
and i just had them all written out and
i memorized my jokes in the steam room
and because it was getting hot i'm
sweating and it's kind of hard to
concentrate i feel like it made me
memorize my jokes number one differently
i was looking at them different i wasn't
like you know what i'm saying like it
really i was also high too so um but it
was also like i just feel like you're
kind of just changing something people
do like you know people do naked shows
in comedy right where they get naked and
do their jokes some people think it's
stupid i think it's kind of an
interesting thing because if you're
doing your jokes and there's this
extreme thing where you're super
self-conscious embarrassed whatever it
is and you and you still go up and
you're trying to kill
there's something interesting about that
exercise there's something interesting
about kind of like challenging yourself
and also
performing your jokes in that way you're
never going to go that far you know what
i'm saying you're never going to get
that experience so who knows where
you're gonna go with that joke or
something you might say that you would
never say in a million years so i think
it can be valuable
i thought i thought it was crazy i never
looked at it from that perspective i
always thought it was crazy it is kind
of crazy i wouldn't do it if i had a big
dick i'd do it no if i
listen i'd do it with a little dick
that's where you get more action right
now no little dick [ __ ] and
they take their password that's when
they get action because the chicks feel
bad for you so they'll try to suck that
thing big
and they'll realize that's just a
[ __ ] old folks tale no
that's not true this is not true
who would go to see nude comedy unless
she was going to support somebody but
that's three in the room without crazy
nude comedy creeps unless one of the
chicks was banging on that and we're
just gonna sit there and salivate at the
mouth and then go up to her afterwards
tell her how great she was
we're doing this
we're doing a naked rose battle we
combined the two hottest shows the naked
show and the roast battle at skankfest
the comedy festival we run that i tried
so hard to get your ideas to come out
too
so [ __ ] hard the hardest man in the
world of the book so what we're doing
what are you it's a naked rose battle
okay oh my god yeah yeah but people dude
it was the hottest we did last year it
was [ __ ] crazy we had some hot chicks
on it this year but there's some some
people are not good looking at all
but it's like uh i'm telling you it's
not as it's not it's not as weird as you
think man is the reason it's packed out
it's gonna be like crazy packed
um but the that side of it goes away
very quickly the sexual side of it it's
like you're really watching them for
like the embarrassment just what you're
almost on the edge of your seat waiting
to see what happens
and it was pretty cool everyone's very
respectful nobody takes pictures like we
have where you can't take out your phone
or anything
um
but yeah it's pretty cool i think you i
think you dig it man i think i think
yeah ari shafir he judged it last year
he was doing it again this year naked
completely naked uh earl skakel's coming
out to judge it completely naked bronson
jones
these guys all got big [ __ ] dicks
though
so that's it i mean
that's really what it comes down to if
you got a big dick boom or a hilariously
tiny dick but if you have an average
side stick or a slightly below average
size deck like me
no it's not gonna work man
it looks like it looks like a big toe
my dick when it's not hard yeah it's a
shower right yeah yeah yeah what are you
supposed to do it just sinks in and it's
gonna sink into my body like it's just
gonna slowly protrude and turn into a
[ __ ] i'm telling you when you're
embarrassed oh and you're in front of
people it's not like you don't to like
get it ready like you're gonna have sex
like you don't want to vote no you're
not blowing up there's no way there's
nothing sexual about it so there's no
way i want to get i'm gonna get boned up
and keep it semi-erect no if you're
embarrassed [ __ ] that
is there a rule like don't talk about
well obviously for the for the roast
maybe there is for there isn't but for
the comedy like i would think everyone
would be talking about being naked it
might get a little bit do people like
try to do their regular jokes i guess i
don't know i only saw it once and it was
to see hot chicks but i'm sure other
people
it's so crazy how
the only thing i'm interested in is
stand up calm
yeah like it's so short-sighted
it's so like it's
so unlike me but that's all i ever want
to do no like i remember they'd invite
me to do latino comedy i needed the 50
bucks i would do the show but it really
bothered me like why can't we just do
comedy yeah you know what i'm saying
because we got six picks on the [ __ ]
lineup or whatever
all those type of things always
i went somewhere one night and they were
doing a show and they asked me to go up
and then after every joke they play the
horn
i was ready to take that horn and
[ __ ] light on [ __ ] fire
i'm one of those guys
let me just do my ten minutes and i need
to do whatever you want i don't like uh
there's just a lot of things and they're
very interesting ideas and i i
understand where they're coming from
i just don't know if i understand though
i can never roast anybody
i could
but i don't want to no you don't want i
don't want it but here's the thing you
don't though
it's so [ __ ] weird how i don't want
i'm interested you do you do this
podcast so it's the same [ __ ]
technically look at all this right it's
just changing some of the variables
changing some of the parameters it's
just another form of
whatever your comedy is you put it in
whatever vessel or vehicle if you do if
you win for a roast it's joey diaz right
if you do a podcast it's joey diaz if
you're [ __ ] sitting in a car smoking
a bum with your boy talking joey diaz
stand up boom same thing they book you
on rolls because it's you you know what
i'm saying you you're the you get cassie
because it's you you know what i'm
saying right so all your comedy always
goes into that so in my opinion i'm
going like all of these things are just
kind of practice for the industry
somebody's going to tell you to write on
a tv show one day you got to take your
former comedy and put it into this other
vehicle maybe you're not comfortable
doing that so you do a roast battle you
do some [ __ ] stupid shows some you
know specialty show brand new you know
read from a newspaper come up with a
joke on the on the spot or whatever um
i think it's also exercising a muscle
being how bad i am yeah like uh but you
don't need to you're a [ __ ] headliner
you know yeah no no no these guys matter
you know you know i did uh what's his
name what's the photographers troy
conrad has a show set list the set list
oh i ate a bag of dicks
a bag of things that was all brand new
jokes i don't know what it is it's like
they throw a topic i thought it was the
one with the screen behind you right i
don't know i think i didn't want to
remember
all right
i just it's just it just doesn't it's a
really popular show just wanted to stand
up
joey will not be there yeah i want to do
my 15 minutes and go home if you're
playing the flute and all that [ __ ] i'm
not in if you got a horn or an mc that's
a [ __ ] and that's your novelty
one of the ones i saw you at once was a
burlesque one with like the naked woman
running around backstage and
look freaked out a little bit you know
they do not need to and i i i don't want
to hate because i know there's a lot of
shows that do this but it's a problem
they do these burlesque slash comedy
shows and i think the ones that are
successful are all female because i know
somebody in new york who does one with
all females and all female comedians and
they kind of have like a code where you
don't make fun of the burlesque chicks
right but i did one where it was like
they just mixed in regular comics that
didn't did they were showing up for a
[ __ ] gig and then these burlesque
chicks were showing up for a gig and you
know we're just [ __ ] [ __ ] so all
the comics are just making jokes about
these chicks these are elastics they're
very serious about what they do as like
an art like you know we're just [ __ ]
calling them hookers basically and just
having no respect for what they do and
we were wrong technically but i mean
they were not happy they like when they
were like really like they were it was
like a whole thing you can't combine
those worlds or at the very least if
you're going to do that everybody's got
to be aware they do that at bar shows a
lot where it's like somebody will book a
bar show and they'll be in all they'll
be people at the bar show just hanging
out like just watching a game or
whatever having some beers with their
friends and then eight o'clock hits boom
and they turn off the tvs and then they
drop some shitty comedy show on them and
then you're interrupting their life like
this is where they go every day after
work and then all sudden this is this
new comedy show
and then boom you gotta [ __ ] be
dropped into their world
now
let me tell you one thing
now you come to me and you go joey let
me talk to you i got this spot in the
bronx
i got 12 dancers all of them at 10.
it's 50 to get in they're all banging
it's a strip club all nude i need for
you to do 15 minutes pick up the small
250 would you do me a favor
yes
you know why
because lenny bruce did strip clubs so
i'm always opening the strip club i
don't mind and guess what don't invite
me to one that serves steak
or lobster
i want to smell the [ __ ] yeast
infection as i come through the door
because that's where i fit in yeah if
you invite me to the one with the steaks
and the cabaret
it's not the same it's two different
types of pizzas
i know what i'm looking for i know if
you came to me and said joy i got a
brilliant idea i got a guy over it
[ __ ] whatever he'll give you this
amount of money i got this strip club
it's called the cave it's in the bronx
and the boogie down they got a german
shepherd from security guard you know
you know and i know already what you're
saying to me joey joey you would kill at
this room come down i would tape a
[ __ ] hbo special there yeah with
chicks behind me dancing [ __ ] putting
bottles in that [ __ ] and i just look
straight ahead and keep [ __ ]
throwing throwing throwing yeah i
believe in that the c-section scars in
their body a little bit overweight yeah
no no i want them to be banging well
here's the thing maybe one could be shot
one got shot she lost the [ __ ] finger
i don't mind like japanese there's two
different types of people right yeah so
there's the people that will go
and this is lee and this is not enough
this is you're a better person like so
don't take this offensively
you're the type of people that'll be
like hey let's go to a strip club right
and
lee's the type of guy that's going to
bring he's going to look up on google
what's the best strip club like where's
the nicest place to go it's going to
have a dress code right it's going to
have a dress code it's going to be it's
yeah of course make sure that the party
is fine they're gonna have a reservation
um you know it's gonna be amazing it's
gonna be this a really incredible
experience to be a bachelor party uh
unreal everyone have their nice clothes
on it's gonna be unreal
me and you
it's like i'm gonna say joe you want to
go to strip club you'd be like all right
cool
me and you were not gonna tell anybody
that we're going there because it's not
we're not proud of this we're not
bringing our friends we're not bringing
a big group of people and it's going to
be
an hour out of new york city it's going
to be in a borough like deep in brooklyn
and it's going to be all black and
puerto rican chicks it's going to be
[ __ ] hardcore ghetto and those
[ __ ] will [ __ ] you for 40
and that's the type of strip club that
we go to with 200 people in the audience
and you do a comedy show they would go
[ __ ] crazy and let me tell you
something lee
when you go to that place the silver or
whatever
and you have the steak and the lobster
and when you see one of your [ __ ]
idiotic buddies and he'll go highly like
hi stan
and next time you're with your wife
and you're walking in a farmer's market
that's the type of [ __ ] that'll
come to you and go we had such a great
time that night right in front of your
wife
when i see you in a strip club that's
like me and my boy talking about i can
see you getting your dick sucked the
next time i see you at christmas i won't
even mention it what i'm saying
like you won't even mention it there's
nothing you don't even have to come up
to me and go joey that night you saw me
[ __ ] that chick without a condom in
the ass you didn't say no it's
understood outside those walls we don't
say nothing
because we got a mutual respect those
are different places yeah the type of
strip club you go to your wife would be
okay with you going as long as you
promise and not get a lap dance
i just sit there and watch
no wife would ever approve of the strip
club they were talking about there was a
place called sweet cherries in brooklyn
that was like just [ __ ]
a problem or was it chair
i think it was sweet cherries yeah this
place was like legitimately like
everyone had a gun it was crazy but the
girls would give you a hand job for
twenty dollars you're gonna get a lap
dance for ten dollars in the back
they're just gonna jerk you off for 20
let me ask you guys a question
if tonight
i got in my car
and i went for a ride and i go i'm kind
of thirsty let me go to 7-eleven
and i went to 7-eleven while i was there
i said you know what i'm a little
energetic today
let me go over here the deja vu 52 good
looking ones three fat ones
let me go over there and see what's
going on i stop at the atm i take out a
deuce
if i walk in there and i get one lap
dance because that's what i usually
would do i go to a strip club and i'll
get one lap dance
i'll put a couple dollars in her string
the best looking one i don't even play
with it
i know that she's up there naked and
she's got a kid somewhere let me go give
her a fin just to make a night
that's it once i get in my car it's
never repeated again i don't even tell
lee
i don't know why anybody would go home
and tell their wife they do anything no
i don't volunteer no information to
nobody no paper trail no don't talk
about it you don't say [ __ ] i don't know
i grew up being a cheater on women and
as long as you don't talk there's no
cheating shut the [ __ ] up you didn't say
nothing that's it there's no cheating i
didn't get my dick sucked i went i saw a
chick dance
i put a fin and the other one's the
thing and i got a lap dance from one and
i kept my fingers to my side yeah and i
came in my pants nobody [ __ ] cheat i
get in my car take a tissue i wipe my
helmet i throw it out the car door i let
her [ __ ] the indian with the tear in his
eye i make a u-turn and i go home
why would you go home and go i went to a
strict club with joy shut the [ __ ] up
you don't know nothing where'd you go we
went for a ride
yeah where'd you go for a ride what what
what what what the [ __ ] school paper
all right all right i don't know he was
talking we're talking you're giving her
ammunition for the future yeah she will
hold
she just puts in a little bank
so and you [ __ ] that tell your
girlfriends you're going to vegas with
your buddies it's boys night out
i should shoot you
if i had the balls i would line you up
against the wall and shoot you if you're
gonna have a boys night out don't tell
her and then you're gonna break up walls
and go to vegas and she's gonna come
back at you when you're home one time
and go guess what we're doing we'll have
an atlantic city girls night out and
you'll see it's not gonna [ __ ] feel
too good so shut the [ __ ] up yeah can i
say the problem yeah what is it social
media man
somebody's going to take a picture no
nobody takes pictures and my crew nobody
takes pictures no pictures just leaving
your crew man he's out there taking
pictures i'm telling you man he knows
better to take a camera and take a
picture no there's a and there's some
people like dean dower i got to tell him
right off the bat dean delray hasn't
even said hello to you and he's turning
around to take a picture i don't know
[ __ ] pictures
i don't know pictures i know you stop at
the [ __ ] pictures
i just saw you right here
you know i'm off yeah i'm off the clock
get the [ __ ] out of here with a [ __ ]
camera
no there's no pictures why are we really
is it it's a culture obsessed with
taking pictures
because that's how they were
when i went back to shoot the
documentary lee i totally 15 times not
to put the camera away
but i also told lee that people are
going to tell him he put the [ __ ]
camera away i know where i grew up we
weren't there 15 minutes and somebody
don't put the [ __ ] camera down why is
that camera you know
i come from a society we didn't take
pictures yeah that you can't find the
picture of me when i was 15 or 16 or 17
or 18. they didn't take pictures yeah
there's i have to say we're snoring tons
of blow and there's no pictures yeah i
know a thousand parties i went there's
no cameras nobody came out with a kodak
i went to the uh
the bunny ranch
in uh reno is that where it's at i think
right outside of reno
and because we did a podcast thing there
they're like we were we were for the you
know the guy who owns it his birthday
party we're doing like podcasts and
interviewing people and [ __ ]
so uh
yeah dude i was like there was i took i
uh
i took out my camera for a second or not
my camera my phone to like send a text
message
and this girl comes and sits in my lap
and she goes take it oh yeah [ __ ] yeah a
couple more stars of death guys ready to
set the record i already i thought i
said the record already well
24. i'm 924 right now you might as well
go for broke and let these [ __ ]
know
nobody comes into lee's territory and
breaks his record you understand me oh
what's lee's record 26. what is this
right now that uh
two and five the seven that's that's not
much he's killing me right now joey yeah
no i want i don't want you to go down
you have a show than that i want you to
be well i'm fine um i told you right now
last time you didn't believe me
very limited i'll take a bong hat
whatever you want i'm not [ __ ] i'm
telling i'm gonna give you the savage
yeah do the savage of death i love it
but no the girl sits down on my lap
and she goes uh she goes taking a
picture she told she literally told me
to take a picture she's a prostitute i
was like what i was like i could take a
picture she was like yeah what are you
talking about
those girls out there because it's legal
this their whole game is social media
their pictures they have profiles on the
website it's crazy it's such a weird
thing when you go to that that situation
where it's legal it reminds me when i
was in amsterdam or i guess not even
that's so funny because i i [ __ ] in
cali it's like legal now it's kind of
that way in cali now if you come back
from cali to new york city you go from
smoking weed
you know very freely and very like
whatever everyone just does it to going
back to new york city and feeling like a
[ __ ] criminal and that's how it was
with like prostitution out there like
everybody's very they kind of like laugh
about it they're kind of open about it
you know
welcome
have you ever been to uh thailand or
anything like that to do it because like
i've there's people who travel now just
for that just to go to prostitutes yeah
well
are you here if you go to if you go to
thailand because you're looking for
little six-year-old boys no they have
girls there too
well yeah six-year-old [ __ ] girl no
oh god
you know uh
like i said i've never been a big
picture guy
all right you know after the show you
really really want to go out
after every show and every [ __ ] city
i'd really really like to go out and get
a beer but you know why i can't
because they wouldn't stop with the
[ __ ] pictures all night and that just
gets annoying what we do on stage and
[ __ ] that's one thing you came to the
show you waited around we took pictures
once i go to the bar you're done and i
did two shows yeah that's it and people
will keep coming back the same people i
just met him he loves don't know what
are you advertising for [ __ ] pictures
for i don't need you advertising for
[ __ ] pictures come take a [ __ ]
picture like i'm a [ __ ] carnival ride
you know that's why i can't go out i
can't go eat you go to a diner you read
i don't want to bother you while you're
eating no but then why the [ __ ] you
bothering me i wish joey diaz
i wish the the 17 18 year old joey diaz
could hear this the problems oh no
listen
i just want to explain to people i would
love to go to a bar afterwards but
there's always that one [ __ ] family
that won't leave me alone with the
[ __ ] camera
yeah you know they won't leave you alone
i'm not good with drunk people yeah i
don't need their mind i'm not good with
drunk people so i don't know how to act
anymore that's why i avoid it because
it's not
you know you're drunk you you take it
wrong when i go listen enough with the
[ __ ] picture yeah because there comes
a point i'll look at you i mean even if
even if you're sober that's oh yeah
enough with the picture don't take a
[ __ ] hike all right and they just
look at you like but they have to feel
it like come on
you get ten [ __ ] pictures i'm i'm
really bad as well because i'm so
appreciative of people that want to take
pictures oh no i'm a preacher bro i'll
hang out for [ __ ] hours no no but
that's a problem though like when you
you get it on a higher level you know
you you have a very very large fan base
so i'm sure it's like you know
frustrating after a con you know hanging
out
it's not frustrating i learned early on
that you got to take pictures with
people they paid they came to your show
that's not the [ __ ] point right
there's a time and place for everything
in life
yeah there's a time and a place
forever i just feel very awkward like if
somebody asked me for a picture even if
they're being annoying about it even do
i have people that do this no i take the
picture with them no but i wish like i
could go you know what i'm eating right
now my family yeah like oh that's a
little weird i would say if i was if i
was with my son i would definitely say
that sometimes i don't even say it i
feel bad for them for not knowing oh
yeah that's crazy you don't [ __ ] know
yeah if i'm with my kid don't come up to
me
my son's mother i had to stop putting
pictures of my son on instagram
because uh somebody came up to my son's
mother
she was on the subway platform and she
came up to him and was like uh oh my god
i love your son
and she was like what she was like yeah
yeah james and she knew his name
and then it was it was a chick and she
wasn't like meaning any harm by it but
she was just like you know and my son's
mother called me up she's like i have
people [ __ ] recognizing my kid don't
put pictures of
i put them up on facebook because it's a
limited group it's a you know it's a
close group of people
um but yeah it's a weird thing you know
if that's where people should understand
like that should be and it doesn't mean
it shouldn't have to be even be spoken
should be unspoken if somebody's with
their family or their child
well
it's there's a lot of good you go into
you you dropped the car
i'm [ __ ] thankful
that i'm at this age i'm still doing
comedy i'm more thankful than most
people because i know where i came from
i was in a [ __ ] hole so
i appreciate everything
everything
the the only problem i have
and today i bumped into three i bump
into people
all the [ __ ] time from the podcast
and they're really it's great
i love it really is
no matter where the [ __ ] you go you bump
into two people that'll come up to you
okay quick i mean it's crazy you'll see
it you see it you see it it's crazy
but it's during the shows
it's when it gets hectic like i don't
sell t-shirts
you know why don't sell t-shirts
so you come talk to me i don't want you
to go i don't have the 20 for the
t-shirt i don't sell t-shirts yeah i
want you to come talk it's awkward
especially if you listen to the church
yeah i really want you to come over and
i'll take the picture with you the whole
thing but then there's people that while
the line is thinning
they'll come back
can i take another picture of my
girlfriend that one didn't come out okay
okay ching ching
okay then they leave
then the line is standing and they come
back
and this time they come back with
another couple and they want individual
pictures and a full picture with the
other cops
you know
you just go enough and they're not quick
about listening no and then they want to
tell you a joke or he's drunk and he
grabs you by the neck yeah told joe
rogan to come to me yeah i'm gonna go
home and tell joe rogan get your life
together yeah by the time like tomorrow
morning comes i forgot whatever the [ __ ]
you said to me about joe rogan or dennis
the melissa
you know it's it's just
really super there's people coming to me
to tell joe rogan that this is a cool
place i always tell anybody if i go to a
cool place i'll tell you man that magic
bus
magic bag in michigan is cool and that
place in milwaukee do the podcast there
it's cool too the pabst
perhaps in the little one to turn the
hall ballroom
those are cool little places around the
country man there's now there's great
clubs i have no problems
with none of them it's just certain
things that sometimes like if i go to a
7-eleven and there's 20 people on the
line
these people will take that camera and
just grab me
and put the camera
yeah
what the [ __ ]
if i just grabbed you louis gomez what
would you do to me as a human being late
if i just grabbed your shoulder and
pulled you towards me kiss you
lee would probably [ __ ] punch me in
the face and you would leave me in the
balls yeah you can't do that to people i
accept that yeah and i'm sure there's a
difference for people who like if people
recognize you from movies so now i go up
to the line and now he just embarrassed
the [ __ ] out of me in front of the whole
line of people
and now he's telling people nah he's the
guy with joe rogan and he also was in
the sopranos i was never in the [ __ ]
sopranos
and now they start [ __ ] that now i
got eight people in the line who want to
take [ __ ] surprises
it's [ __ ] crazy
it's [ __ ] crazy
i love
having surprises when they come up to me
and they go we love you on the sopranos
there's times i play them
yeah depending on who they are and how
many they are sometimes i run for
[ __ ] an hour yeah yeah i did the
sopranos for 18 years you know whatever
i just [ __ ] with them what about i was
with him one time where he told the
people no i wasn't and they they refused
to believe they're like come on you can
just tell we're not going to bother you
you were nice guys he's like guys i i
wasn't in this one and eventually you
just took the picture
because they refused to believe
they were like they were trying to get
over on them that's fine number one time
at sony i was shooting spider-man 2.
and i'm outside this [ __ ]
if they run out of trailers and sony
they have this
in the middle they have hotels you don't
know their hotels on the other side
they're like dressing rooms but they're
tremendous so the size of this they got
a couch they got a screen
they got a phone you know air
conditioning and you just go in there
they got a thing to hang your [ __ ]
clothes no bathroom you gotta go in the
hallway
but i remember one time standing in
front of that smoking dope and they were
doing a tour
at sony down in culver city they were
doing a tour culver city
and dug these people on the little
trains you know like when they take you
you'll see the little trains and people
like
wow this is beautiful and awesome i saw
this couple go like this bro they just
looked at me
and they locked on and all said no wall
stopped them you know that was it
you give them six seconds
these [ __ ] jumped off the train
and came running at me going big [ __ ]
big [ __ ] the people
the [ __ ] guy in the train is going
get back on the train get back on the
train get part of a tour there's a
violation get back on the train they're
like hold on hold on this big [ __ ] i go
no no no i'm joey diaz i'm a comedian
bro
they would not [ __ ] stop
they were relentless
but and i've told this on the show
before
the best one ever was i was coming home
from rascals
yeah jersey
west orange no
to sure
and that night
i found where my buddy's stash was
i was i would stay with him for the
weekend me and him had a deal i would
stay with him for the weekend he would
give me a little bit of blow and [ __ ]
like that but he was a tight wad i knew
he had like an ounce of this room in his
room one day and he had this big rock of
coke and i took this [ __ ] chunk of it
and i hid in the garage and i [ __ ]
and his mother made chicken colors
which are my all-time favorite yeah with
cream corn and mashed potatoes stop
security with dipped in flour and bread
crumbs
now these that wasn't enough for you
joey you still took his rock oh i had to
take his rock he was a family bro this
guy has died i'm still getting bills
i just got a 17 000 bill for he put my
name under that thing when you go
through the city or gas pass oh yeah and
i owe them 17 grand like i got a [ __ ]
letter my wife went [ __ ] bananas like
a month ago oh he did it again he did it
again he took him you took that rock no
this was please he took the identity way
back to the rock the rock was the least
of his problems yeah
no that was his thought process like you
ate my mom's chicken i ran with him no i
would stay at his house because i kind
of deal with him i grew up with them i i
was kids when i met them yeah and on
friday night i was take his truck
i would fly back and i'd do rascals and
we'd hang out i'd work with him i'd help
him [ __ ] deliver fish and [ __ ] he'd
give me a couple i loved him even if he
didn't give me money you know what i'm
saying i would still do and i liked it
you go to the full fish market should we
get bacon and ham and egg on the [ __ ]
roll in new york at 4 30 in the morning
they do that in california bacon and
cheese on a roll ketchup please go shoot
yourself you got a better chance they do
it they make it no no
three three over easy eggs they always
overcook them too much yeah no no they
won't do them some [ __ ] american
cheese they don't even understand what
they can they'll give it to you and the
[ __ ] yolk the white will still be
soft come on and you're biting yeah yeah
they used to be one place because we
trained the [ __ ] guy
the sunset grill
the sunset drill
i'm gonna tell
yeah
buffy's boyfriend and buffy the vampire
slayer that he's still on tv he looks
like steve runner's easy he's on that
show now with the chick cop on tnt
they've been on for 10 years the kids
got to be a gazillionaire he's from
philly yeah and he used to go in there
one day he went in there and he's
telling the guy
you got to whip the egg good american
cheese all the way yeah put a slice of
tomato on that [ __ ] some ham
put some butt up with some ketchup yeah
fry up the [ __ ] buns he had the guy
training sometimes you open the [ __ ]
little bag croissant yeah someone if you
want to be yeah you want to be high
class one day
spend an extra dollar you're gonna go
you're gonna get upset just get ham and
eggs and call it a [ __ ] day yeah it's
good i like that i like because you have
healthy options here and i went to i
went to this [ __ ] spot and griddle uh
the the griddle um the griddle on the
sunset on the sunset yeah they [ __ ]
killed wow that's a big breakfast that
place was banging did you get the french
toast or something like that i tried it
but i got the healthier [ __ ] i got a
[ __ ] bowl of
meat and eggs cause i'm back on the diet
that's why
they give you like potatoes there
yeah
i tell them to hold the potatoes yeah no
no obviously you haven't been that dog
no i haven't really done anything i
haven't been in the apple pan or
anything you don't need to go to younger
plan take your wife to this [ __ ]
place for breakfast it's ridiculous
or not during the week probably no
you're not during the week no no not
even on the saturday you gotta go these
people go out on friday those type of
people go to hard shows on friday yeah
that place used to be dead then lindsay
lohan went in there one day before her
trial
and that place started getting packed
yeah that place gets [ __ ] packed
and i like it i like it i just don't
have the patience to wait but if you set
the counter there's always a spot i
would i would let if like if you're
grading it on like a 10-point system for
food i would lose
two or three points in quality of food
for a quieter restaurant that i don't
have to deal with people being around me
bumping into [ __ ] waiting for food i
like i love great food but i also i hate
crowds right no no no no no i don't like
conversation yeah i was at lunch today
it was no it was not busy it was three
tables you know quiet very classy place
it was a hotel really nice it was at
beverly hilton
my buddy was staying there
and we're sitting there and for no
reason at all there's a speaker right
there they just start blaring like jazz
music
yeah you want to [ __ ] break the
speaker we're just having a conversation
everyone's having a good time nobody's
complaining about it
but that that type of chaos when i'm
eating and i'm having i i this what i
hate because this is i don't know if
they do this here but in new york city
jazz brunch is huge
so it's like they have like a live jazz
band in the restaurant it's a [ __ ]
nightmare it's a nightmare they're
playing it's a drum set
joey he's playing drums while you're
trying to eat breakfast
imagine that
imagine there's a drummer
this far from you [ __ ] doing drum
rolls about a gospel [ __ ] brunch
where people are jumping up and down
the blues or something yeah i did it one
time i wanted to shoot myself because
once i eat i eat i don't want to dilly
dally if you think i'm gonna talk to you
over people i i was just telling i was
just telling you guys how i don't like
going out but i do like going out you
know what i can't go out today
because everywhere i go i gotta yell and
i'm deaf
i don't i can't talk over music all
night those days are over i don't want
to hear pool balls
i don't want to walk around people
playing darts
darts flying by your head are you trying
to eat yeah no no no yeah let's get in
the bar let's go to a nice place you
don't need to eat maybe a bowl of chili
with onions and sour cream and crackers
but besides that just to go to a bar
and sit that's all i want to do when i
go to a bar yeah same thing with food
like these people i i read somebody's
post on facebook a couple weeks ago
they went to a dinner party i wouldn't
go to a [ __ ] dinner party
if you're [ __ ] painting what's it
doing is that like where couples get
together and oh hi so what do you do
i'm a [ __ ] host of a [ __ ] podcast
what's it called skank fest you know
like that you know i'm saying
really what is the purpose i'd love to
listen to what you want mm-hmm no you
want why are you wasting my time eating
your food and shut your [ __ ] mouth
the [ __ ] you bothered me i didn't think
that really happened yeah
sure why not we're going to the hospital
anyways i got my room all set up joey
joe that's why i love you because when i
first met you
you were one of the first people that i
had never met before that i was able to
speak to and have a conversation with
and be like comfortable it's very rare
for me i have a difficult time doing
that with people so i never
people think i'm an [ __ ] because like
i if i casually know you i don't really
go up to you and have conversations i
just kind of keep to myself i'm in my
head whatever it is
so i'm not like a social guy like that
it's a very social uh social comedy
scene
no you have to be
social in the scene and you have your
favorites yeah you'll be friends with
everybody people that you know they
don't like you but you like them
you know if i find out somebody doesn't
like me they are [ __ ] dead to me yeah
no i can love them i can think of the
coolest person in the world and then i
find out they don't like me and then
that's that they are [ __ ] out of the
louis j gomez business do you torment
them
you just put them under a [ __ ]
chinese torch you tie them up and you
drop water on their forehead yeah for
three [ __ ] that's exactly
what you're gonna see that only when
they tie you up and water just hits your
forehead plop well i think you've done
that to me a couple of times shortly
mentally through the [ __ ] weeds and
they say after after a long after
however long it'll
burrow a hole through your head right no
no like the drops it's chinese water
torture isn't that what it is i thought
it just drove people crazy i don't think
it would borrow maybe it would who knows
i don't know maybe i'm just making some
[ __ ] up
no i don't they say that it would like
borrow a hole through your head i
believe in family i believe eventually i
believe that if i was married to your
sister
i was allowed to go to your house and
then after a year you liked me and we
did podcasts
it doesn't really matter it's just
it's just a she's a crazy [ __ ] joe you
don't want all puerto rican women are
what's what's that you don't want any of
that it doesn't matter i'm just saying
hypothetically
and
i'm part of your family maybe you have a
brother and he has a wife and they have
a kid i understand that concept
i understand the concept of you and i
and your sister and your parents and
about my parents and
your media family getting together
christmas your mom's birthday and your
dad's birthday that's pretty insane i
get that
but for you to call me i'm hi
my wife is having a party she's
sponsoring it for the you know and also
there's going to be chef antoine
ruga which right away i'm turnt off
and she starts with some spiel or
they're gonna have duck or something i
don't want to go there no duck no i
don't do that like they don't even cook
themselves they hire like a caterer
before i rather you cook yeah there's
little barbecue
i'm a barbecue guy
i like a good barbecue that you know
what hold on time out a barbecue it's
just a house party in the backyard
are you doing a barbecue for the
festival in new york uh no it's gonna be
too crazy dude there's gonna be [ __ ]
500 people enough space if it's like 300
it's it's crazy
it's gonna be nuts
no room for barbecue but the place
serves tacos and good food and you know
we got a it starts off in one venue
which is the creek in the cave which is
you know two there's an upstairs
downstairs plus a big back patio
and then uh later in the evening once it
starts to really fill up we're moving
over into a huge like industrial loft
space which is like fits 500 people but
it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy
yeah
but i love a good barbecue i love uh
getting together and just that's the
other thing when you're doing no carbs
barbecue it's very easy to do no carbs
you just show up boom give me two
burgers throw some cheese on it a little
coleslaw on top of it
done no bun
ribs ribs easy
hot dogs the sugar in the barbecue gives
you carbs so well i think i like you you
know i know what you're saying i don't
know no i'm sorry see um see what i'm
saying don't feel good does it i will
marry your sister hypothetically
hypothetically we don't talk about the
sugar in the [ __ ] barbecue sauce
but if you want to tell me i wouldn't
marry your sister then i gotta go wait
let's just thinking about it you i'm
keeping my barbecue sauce you can marry
my sister is it bad the barbecue sauce
yeah you make you make it no i don't
make my own [ __ ] come on man what are
you doing for labor day memorial daily
i don't think anything i don't even
don't we have a well
i don't i've never had it off i don't
know
we'll probably just
have a day off
or anything special
lady i don't know do you guys do
anything special for it for labor you
gotta eat some [ __ ] food man food we
go out we hunt down barbecues you go
bird's gonna be out of time i don't know
what george is gonna do then this is the
fourth of july my friend damon is having
a [ __ ] barbecue lawn sale
you know everybody's doing something
like that i'll take the i have no soccer
with the baby on saturday which sucks
that's a two-hour
hour activity that now i have to replace
with hand on hand come back chasing her
and [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] how old is your now
four oh yeah my son's four that's right
same exact days yeah gonna push her on
the swing for 32 minutes on the boiling
heat
you're shriveling up like a [ __ ]
raisin
and she's out there higher daddy huh can
i hate outside that's the [ __ ]
i'm already planning for the week and i
have a great time
i smoke a half a number
early and by the time you know i get
tuned up and
she gets a little bicycle and we go
that's it we go and i walk around with a
blah blah blah blah
and then she at one point she'll look at
me and go daddy what do you want to do
much molly because i want to go to
old macdonald and get a [ __ ] chicken
nugget
boom let's go to mcdonald's she hits me
with [ __ ]
uh
the mac and cheese restaurant me and my
wife [ __ ] cringe
that's boston market awesome market yeah
we just cringe i don't like it i got
food poisoning from boston when i was 19
years old yeah no how old what year was
that i'm 35 now so this is 2001
really well that wasn't their peak that
peak was like chelsea
they were everywhere 23rd and 8th in 95
you had to stand online the boston
market
night summer of 94. or kenny kenny
rogers yeah they had one in hollywood i
i shipped blood for me that [ __ ]
chicken that was right
yeah
he still owes me a song at my house
that was the worst piece of [ __ ] food
i had tons of money i was making i had a
type of bell commercial that was running
up the storm i'm taking this [ __ ]
money i'm snorting blow in a hotel in
hollywood and i'm eating every bad food
there is
i'm going from 3 40 to 380 with a
[ __ ] jump i'm not kidding you yeah i
was on an eating tear and i remember
this one particular day i got up
all still [ __ ] up snots in my nose
coke i took a shower
and i went up to get breakfast at that
in those days on saturday night this
diner
they had a karaoke trans
vest night night
and it was big in hollywood on saturday
night look better than a regular
character tonight i went and had the
breakfast there you know when you cooked
up the night before you had 22 [ __ ]
beers
you ate some [ __ ] you spent some money
now you're [ __ ] hungry yeah i
couldn't even eat the breakfast
it looked like the breakfast of my
cousin vinnie
when they gave him the grits and the
eggs were sliding yeah the eggs were raw
and the potatoes were raw
i just looked at the guy i gave him 10
bucks and i walked out and i went to
another breakfast spot that's not there
no more they were tremendous
and i'll never forget by the time i
walked to la brea which is a 20 minute
walk i was already hungry cause
and i shot into kenny rogers
vulture [ __ ] stand over there
and i walked in there and let me tell
you something if trump would have been
the president he would have locked her
down he already had africans working for
this [ __ ] he had like this weird race of
people
there was two restaurants that always
gave me the creeps in hollywood yeah
that kenny rogers when i went in i
didn't think they were legit i thought
this was like a joke because yeah like
africans working in there like the ones
that kidnapped
mr phillips the ones that kidnapped that
what's his name uh
captain phillips captain phillips they
were those type of [ __ ] africans yeah
they weren't big in [ __ ] 97 out here
yeah they just worked there
can i speak to the manager i am the
manager now i am the money like there
was no mr phillips
[Laughter]
there was never a misser
there's lots of pirates and there's
another place i'll never forget
joey medina
lee you ready so just so you don't name
everybody it's 1998.
okay joey medina is taking care of me
like a brother
he's letting me stay in his house rent
free okay
i cause [ __ ] problems he comes back
from whatever
and he takes me for lunch
and we go to a place on vine i think
it's still there i didn't know we were
going he goes go ahead pull in here
and it was dollar chinese restaurant oh
joey it's still good what was the dollar
who the [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
with yeah i looked at him i go what are
we doing
just to see
what the [ __ ] this is you know what i'm
saying all right
you walk in there you hear people
yelling in the back somebody getting
stabbed
shut up and chinese or whatever [ __ ]
mongolian language they're talking is
cats running around no there was no
crashes there's gone there's gone a
bunch of signs all over the place
missing cat reward 225
that mystery meeting the dumpling i
wouldn't eat that [ __ ] out here they're
like the american indians
every part of the animal every part of
the animals the dumplings cost more than
a dollar though yeah yeah that was good
i never went to a what did they have
is everything i didn't eat that no no
are you [ __ ] crazy lisa i told you i
got principles i'm a carmel type of
[ __ ] all right i didn't break i
go joey we can't even he's like why are
you like oh we're gonna die
he's like no i do it all the time
it ain't gonna happen today we went
somewhere else i'll never forget going
in there and seeing like the egg they
had some meal that it does not take it
like that they had a lookout
when a chinese restaurant has a lookout
it's not security it's a guy telling him
his inspection is coming
because that brown meat was either
kangaroo do they have that here the um
the in new york city they started doing
a couple years ago they have to have an
a b or c right rating in the window i
don't want to get you one for 22 dollars
i'll get you an a rating for a year for
the small nickel
they still got roaches in there nobody
you'll see please the place that i've
seen a [ __ ] restaurant up here on
ventura i think lee's gone there three
or four times i've been there two or
three times
every time i [ __ ] went in there you
can't even see the menu dog
you gotta [ __ ] put a blowtorch it's
so dark in there they give you one
candle like this
in the darkness let me shut off the
lights just let me give you a [ __ ]
menu yeah lee am i dying am and my
alliance here is it the place of vega oh
doctors
got roaches yeah no that's why it's dark
because they have roaches yeah you're
walking around stepping on crunchy
things [ __ ] thinking man the
carpeting is fresh you're hearing
it's than [ __ ] i just put two and two
together but wait wait if you turn i
grew up with roaches if you turn the
lights on they scatter they need to have
[ __ ] bright lighting they need
lighting like this studio lights well
why would you they needed lisa to go in
there and [ __ ] do the lighting if the
customer can't tell
if the customer you just told them joey
i didn't tell them i'm just telling you
that that you know telling the fans
that's why they have the lights down so
you don't see the roaches yeah
that's crazy i was at a place once with
a chick and once again i don't know what
it is i don't know why i'm aggressive in
so many situations but for some reason
like if somebody does me wrong right
like if somebody is a dick like if a
waiter's a dick to me i'll make a scene
you know what i'm saying i'm not saying
it's right i'm just saying that i'm i
will i will very quickly say something
right but i was at a restaurant once
with a chick we were younger me and a
few friends in the shake and a huge you
know new york city you guys do you guys
have water bugs here oh
not a lot of places i don't have them
where i live now but
a huge cockroach that can fly oh they're
terrible lee and they're all over miami
it's crazy going to the southwest south
west i had israeli cockroaches
i just sprayed my shaving cream at it
how big
it seemed like that but i don't know it
was like seven years ago there's real
israeli cockroaches yeah there was it
was the only one i've ever seen and and
now i've seen more of some fallen you
and your island get away they got snakes
in the bungalows and [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] sleeping no no no no
leave me alone please they torture they
torture palestinian cockroaches
you know i got a little bit of a
temperature
i don't know if it's where i ate
yesterday
you know i got a four year old who who
the [ __ ] knows you know what i'm saying
like you never know
but it's uh majority i ate at that bake
wings oh but now yesterday [ __ ] i ate
everything at the house
so my stomach could not be sick from
what i ate at the house i had scrambled
eggs
with wheat toast and i think she made uh
what the [ __ ] did she make for lunch
uh shrimp garlic shrimp
with rice
i blew a couple farts from the garlic
and that was it
my stomach was tip top [ __ ] magoon
yeah right as soon as i finished those
wings when i went to the economy store i
started having a little problem
they're good wings i had them i i jus
my airbnb was across the street from it
no no they weren't good wings that was
the [ __ ] problem
they destroyed my intestines something
they put on those [ __ ] things what
flavor did you get we got a combo with
things and every one of them was bad so
every one of them was [ __ ] a horror
show the one they had was really good it
was like a dry rub barbecue or uh yeah
[Laughter]
nobody makes a better chicken wing than
a puerto rican yeah chinese come in a
tight second oh yeah shiny like shitty
chinese what about this thing i always
worry about this
because you you're one of the only
people who like really [ __ ] know
right
so
because you gotta like go to both i
guess i guess there are a lot of people
that live on both coasts but
with like chinese do they have the same
type of shitty chinese food restaurants
here that they have in new york like you
walk up it's a hole in the wall you get
like uh you know six chicken wings for
like [ __ ]
you know through 250.
they got everything here like if you go
to lancashire that little hut over there
they'll sell you chicks they're koreans
they'll cook whatever the [ __ ] you want
there and if they don't have it they'll
get it that's not on the menu though i
don't think i had a [ __ ] he's talking
about the places with like the color
like the menu pictures they took like
yeah yeah
really i wouldn't walk in any of those
things in new york that's like a staple
pork fried rice like a dollar fifty like
a tub of it
it's great
i'm a big uh
but let me
here you go let me explain something to
you
the definition of a slice
i know enjoy you're a fat [ __ ]
the definition of a slice you know what
slice means to me
cook on the move
on the move
okay when i walk into when i'm in new
york city
and i'm [ __ ] doing my thing and
awesome i gotta go i gotta go in the
murkier waters
and but i'm gonna eat i'm gonna eat meat
louie gomez to eat at seven but it's for
[ __ ] thirty i'm starving i'm not
gonna be able to eat little gomez but i
gotta catch this [ __ ] train over here
you walk into a place in new york you
look at the [ __ ] whatever was behind
the counter you look at the cheese slice
you go one he takes the slice throws it
in the [ __ ] oven
he asks you if you want a soda no he
charges you he turns around and gives
you the slice you're on your way
that's what a slice is gonna have that
here
you ready
hi i want a slice what kind of slice
do you want chips with that do you want
cheddar cheese on you you know it's
always a dilemma and then once they give
you the slice they give you a receipt
and they take the bottom and they give
it to the mexican
and they make the poor mexican stop what
he's doing he's got to wipe his hands he
was just washing a pot in the back and
he takes the slices new pair of gloves
and he puts it on now you got to wait
through that whole ballet
now he gets a call on the phone and he
runs over that he's on the phone talking
to his mother from mexico he hasn't
heard from her three years she just got
released
and there goes your [ __ ] slice of
pizza there's a place right down the
corner over there house of pie
whatever every day you walk by there if
you're a fat [ __ ] like me you're like
let me go in there and get a piece of
pie now you walk up to the counter okay
hopeful you walk up to the counter and
it's old school [ __ ]
you dunking donuts what's old-school
dunkin donuts this shit's behind you lee
you've been in there kamish i know i
have a house of pies magnolia 50 feet up
from eat
and then next to it they got like a
coffee place i won't step foot in those
[ __ ] i've never been there when
my wife was pregnant one day she goes i
can go for a piece of pie go you know
what what a coincidence a pie place
opened up in magnolia we went over there
you ever go to a [ __ ] greek diner
yeah of course ask him for a slice of
[ __ ]
pie see how long it takes them to
[ __ ] with dirty hands they go get
that [ __ ] strawberry shortcake
and put it on your dish not this place
yeah ready for this you got to walk it
now the chick is right there
the pies are right behind her
sliced
pre-sliced pre-sliced
she takes your let me get an apple pie
traditional and my wife wants pumpkin
pie okay 482
you put two dollars in the tip jar she
gives you receipts she takes that
receipt and she brings it all the way to
the kitchen to poncho
and god knows what the [ __ ] pablo is
doing back there
then he comes all the way back he picks
up the two pies picks him up walks them
all the way to the kitchen
takes a slice out takes the other slice
up picks the pies back puts them on the
thing because god forbid he bring your
slice back first that's customer [ __ ]
service nobody told them nobody told him
he'll do the he'll do your two slices
left and in the middle
stop and talk to a waiter have a
conversation and breathe yeah on both
your [ __ ] pies
why would i want to eat your [ __ ] pie
you just added 10 minutes to a dilemma
that didn't need to exist turn your
skinny [ __ ] ass around scoop those
two pieces by put them on there charge
me i don't care if your hands are dirty
isn't that something weird that i
noticed they they do this at places
right too much smartness they added too
much brains to the operation when all i
want is [ __ ] simplicity well they you
they have to like uh they have to take
the gloves off and change gloves every
time every time
i mean this has to be a scam by the
glove industry
to [ __ ] make this a law there's no
way i want it i like it no i get pissed
off
one pair of gloves for every like i'd
say every 30 sandwiches but i have a
there's a difference if you think that
that's the dirtiest [ __ ] that's touching
your sandwich is this person's [ __ ]
gloved hands i understand not fingers
because they're touching [ __ ] all day
but if they put a glove on and they're
sitting at a station making sandwiches
they don't need to change their gloves
every time
i think if they leave their gloves on
for you know an hour whatever it is
every hour or two if they change them
that's okay well the only thing i the
only reason i'll disagree is uh
allergies if that's the reason but the
reason why i like it
if you're if you're like at a fancy
restaurant fine do whatever you want to
do i trust that you watch you already
beat me with allergies right you don't
have to speak anymore
you know what i'm saying like i want the
people or
like i want people like at that level
to be wearing gloves you already killed
me with allergies obviously that's the
perfect answer at subway i want them to
put three pair of [ __ ] gloves on
when you go to the subway look at the
bathroom work there i want you to double
bag those garbage okay
when you go to subway like you went all
those years lee even with the glove on
the [ __ ] hand
you got to assume you got to assume okay
i love you to death
when you go into a restaurant from now
on you don't need to look at the kitchen
you need to look at the waiter and pray
to god that you got a good one he washed
his hands yeah he didn't finger bang a
[ __ ] hooker last night and didn't
wash his left hand that's not a terrible
you know he puts it on his kid's [ __ ]
your kids macaroni and cheese his
fingers now your kid gets a little rash
the side of his [ __ ] mouth
and nobody knows what's bothering they
won't let him at the boy scouts
[Laughter]
listen i remember one time i got
arrested
i got arrested
and for a warrant
in 85 and 10 10 to fly a t-neck
ten o'flot maybe
and they said we'll let you go i bailed
out but they said we have to bring you
over to
bergen county courthouse wherever the
[ __ ] that was at the time
dawg i had been in jail a [ __ ] day
and i missed both meals i was in county
so they didn't give me nothing i was
[ __ ] starving
my blood pressure's dropping i'm getting
dizzy and [ __ ] this cops transport me go
listen dawg
officer you gotta do me a favor i got no
reason a lot you look at my warrant it's
for [ __ ]
nothing i go look at my police record
like a listen i haven't eaten
i go you gotta do me a favor you gotta
pull over somewhere i'm gonna [ __ ]
drop by the time we get to bergen county
it's gonna be 10 30. i'm gonna have food
in the jail
please officer i'll do anything a
sandwich
and we're driving right by chance
and like i'll tell you what
if you pull over here i'm going there in
order
he goes what do you want he left me in
the back of the car
with the handcuffs on he took money out
of my wallet he went and got me pork
fried rice and a soda
and i [ __ ] ate it in the back of the
car while i'm eating
he says to me
hey
let me tell you a story about that
[ __ ] food you're eating
he goes a few years back there was a
high line thief rubbing robin safes
around the area and the target said that
this was the next place
because this family's [ __ ] kinky
so what we did was we set surveillance
up inside chance
and waited for him to kick down the door
oh he goes let me tell you something
when they turn the lights on
that one one time we all pulled our guns
down we started yelling
it wasn't the guy coming in
it was the amount of rats chance has in
that [ __ ] kitchen okay
he goes and the size of the rats
now
that was 1985 it's 2007.
i s 2017
i still need a [ __ ] chance and i know
about the rats you understand me yeah
but i know what i'm dealing with so what
i got a little rat [ __ ] what do you
think that's the first time i ate rat
[ __ ] in my life before yeah i'm a new
york city type of [ __ ]
you just gotta control what the [ __ ] you
eat yeah let me get some shout outs here
brent rogers
gareth purvis
neon no no no no no no no no no yeah mr
armstrong you know i love you
megan715 young deep soap
young dish soap
don wrangler
ali cupid jacob rogers
and my main man andrew lawrence
not to mention he lost them [ __ ]
mafia down there bobby
holding it down in austin for me my girl
over in michigan
[ __ ] cleo
my main [ __ ] austin who i got
to contact because ralph's not going to
be there july the 8th ooky spooky and
the rest of your [ __ ] savages
don't forget tomorrow night sold out
next thursday though
is wide open over at flappers
7 30 show bing bang boom 10 bucks
what it is is me just working out
materials
leo will be there taping he's the
executive to the executive to the
executive to the executive assistant of
the assistants
and uh we'll have a good time i just got
the title executive added that's very
nice thank you dude i appreciate that
then i got breyer june 8th
through the 10th you brand [ __ ]
thursday night that's the night
anyway that's it and that's then so you
have no plans all the [ __ ] you talk and
the extravagance i always talk so much
[ __ ] i know it's where you going this
weekend you got nowhere to go and nobody
hang out with
i i hadn't thought about it no no i
honestly never even crossed my mind
you're such a good act you know that
that's what i love about you
i'll do stuff i'll i'll um what is your
wife work on saturday
i don't know if she has to work she has
to work two a month i don't know if this
is one of them or not but i don't think
no no i think she has a three day
weekend so i think she's good
joe can i grab some water absolutely my
brother i'm cotton mouth but i will say
1400 milligrams i'm still standing here
pretty easily guys that's crazy i'm very
impressed where's that what'd you say
you cut down well no i thought you said
you want two more no yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's why we have to eat another one no
no no no no no
stop being a [ __ ] later
that's good that's good his record is
28.
my record's 28. he's got to break my
right break his rocking record right now
lately you're gonna look me in the
[ __ ] eyeball after all we've been
through
after all the edibles we ate and you're
gonna tell me you're not gonna have 2800
[ __ ] milligrams you're crazy are you
saying you haven't done it oh please
let me tell you joey diaz does not lie
in the beginning i was eaten i don't eat
them you know you have to remember
i was going to see the russians okay i
would go to the russians and eat two
pieces of banana bread
in those days banana bread had to be
500 milligrams because you couldn't eat
the whole piece
i would eat the entire [ __ ] piece
then i was eating two of them after i
[ __ ] puked green one day in the car
i mean this is crazy [ __ ] come on so
that's 1600
1800
yeah that's 1800 you're doing right now
is that good it just doesn't affect are
you are you high at all i'm really high
i'm fine
i'm feeling great
lee you got to go for 3 000.
you got to set the record straight
tonight that's it that's why i didn't
bring you any chocolate anymore
because i said to myself you know what
we don't need no i won't lead a break
to read i want you see the plaque we got
we got a plaque from
youtube you're gonna get a plaque from
star one
the first guy ever to eat three thousand
milligrams what are you what are you at
right now
i'm at twenty six hundred i don't i
can't do three thousand what's four
hundred dollars
nothing who cares we'll get you some
pizza i don't get you
tomorrow you just got to make sure you
drink a lot of water and you make sure
you go to noho park and walk around so
you sweat it out of your system
and you'll be for what happens if you
don't do that
you don't want it lurking in your
[ __ ] system i mean it it's in your
garage i go to the steam room joey yeah
that takes my [ __ ] takes that top layer
off yeah and you got to do the steam
fits combination what he means like it
goes
and then the [ __ ] other one with the
rocks the hot water
i joined the gym just for the steam room
see what happens to me is what happens
to me in jiu jitsu
once i think about what i'm doing i get
nervous i'm not thinking about it i'm
just super high today twenty six hundred
minutes what's four more hundred at
least do two more hundred so nobody
could even no he's gotta do four hundred
he's gonna break the record why would he
why would he tap out i've broken let him
do two and let him see where he's at two
more hundred and if he's good at 2800 he
hasn't what is the worst that could
happen lee well he's harder than
diabetes
and then you and i will go to [ __ ]
murder for attempted murder for blowing
up
what happens to your heart you've never
complained to me about like my niece
said something about her heart
red band said his heart my heart's going
inside
yeah do you feel it yeah i heard my
heart's being fast yeah that's just love
that's good for you it's like fake
exercise sure your body thinks you're
doing jumping jacks meanwhile you're
sitting there am i crazy is that a
stupid thing because when i'm in the
steam room but after like 30 minutes i'm
really going pretty hard right and my
heart's just going and i'm sweating do
you get high before you go in there oh
yeah yeah it's my favorite thing in the
world too hot today before you get in
there oh you have no idea you have no
idea what it's like to go in the [ __ ]
sauna in the morning nice it's
incredible
and then you shower right afterwards you
never feel cleaner well the ymca in
hollywood was my own time the ymca and
hollywood opened up at 4 30. i guess it
was dead 429 boom boom with a bottle of
[ __ ] uh
hyacinth or whatever that spray is to
open you up yeah yeah yeah absolutely
eucalyptus
eucalyptus so the first thing i would do
is take a nice shower even if i took a
shower at the house
i'd take another hot shower just to get
everybody ready
i'd go into that sauna nice and stoned
to the gills yeah and i'd [ __ ] do
10-15 minutes in there but then after
i'd start stretching that yeah just
light stretching popping open up her
muscles boom
take another cold shower and bam go into
the steam room for a little eucalyptus
stop at least i am yeah it's the best
thing about look this is what i do with
my head i've never i usually see me in a
hat because i shave my head with
clippers now i've been bicking my head
because i'm just at the gym all the time
i go in between spots
because they're all over the city the
gems so i literally go in i'll have an
hour between spots i'll pop in steam for
20 minutes shower shave my head shave my
face boom never felt better never felt
better in my life joey
it's the best thing i've ever done and
then here's the beauty i would get out
of the steam take another shower
then i would jump into the pool
boom into the heated pool like a little
40 minute workout like 20 for pulling
and 40 for kicking i would stretch in
the pool i throw some karate kicks in
this nice warm pool
and i get out and i do it all
over again what's wrong with that lady
what's your problem with that why is
that i actually i just ordered goggles
but no no no
i just don't like it not for not for the
steam obviously that doesn't sound like
heaven
not stoned stoned in hawaii being
overheated freaks me out you've never
done it give it a shot columbus did i've
ever steered you wrong
a few times but still i'll i will go
tomorrow or friday we should all go to
the steam room there's a place on
wilshire it's like a russian bath house
let's go well they give you the massage
no hand job leo all in the up and up
here these are russian men finally i'll
give you a hand job
they put a towel around your waist
they rub you down and they put some
stuff in you they peel it off they'll
shave your head completely or shave your
mustache
you'll look like [ __ ] forget about it
anyway
seriously you didn't know that down i i
think it's in it's in hollywood someday
it's lit yeah russian bath house devon
in the east village they have one i
understand how like this team sounds
great i've been in steam rooms i just
don't really want to get stoned out of
my mind for it no
you do you do
you really do you have no idea how easy
you'll be yeah you don't know what
you're you're too high to even know what
you're saying right now
that could also be and he has he has
talked his way out of eating two more
stars to death to break the record yes
he knows he knows he's going down
that's not overreact there's something
right he's good at that time he's a good
man like that when is the festival
uh it's called skank fest james what is
it are june 23rd through 25th that's
thursday to saturday you know i've done
a friday through sunday it's a friday
night kickoff we have uh red bands doing
a death squad show
uh that friday night um we got dave
smith he's premiering especially he's
got an hour special that we self-produce
that's [ __ ] incredible
um and then on uh all day saturday all
day sunday from noon until 2am it's
content parties it's just basically an
all-day comedy party it's out of control
really great i mean uh headliners this
year jim gaffigan uh artie lang bert
kreischer
uh who else uh duncan trussell ari
shafir big jay okerson [ __ ] uh where's
ari's show at ari's show they're all in
one it's all in one venue except then we
move it's all set up in one venue and
then we move over to that loft space so
it's gonna if you're coming you're gonna
see everything you're hanging out with
everybody that's the difference between
skank fest and other comedy festivals is
this is literally a party where you're
hanging out with all your favorite
comedians as well so it's it's pretty
incredible man it's it's very different
if you i mean you can't go this year but
we're doing a tour next year eight
cities
actually you can go this year
if you follow skankfest nyc on twitter
we're giving away a pair of tickets
every friday
so we have it sold out completely
already sold out completely
kill tony's going to be there uh we got
guide them comedy jam
it's gonna be incredible that's crazy
you got a lot of guys no yeah so we have
110 comics overall throughout the entire
weekend that are on different showcases
different levels and all the same
building
yeah well it's two venues technically
but it's all you know the one in the
earlier part it's in the creek in the
cave and then we will move over to the
gantry loft
very interesting you should be proud of
all the moves you guys are doing i'm
really excited about it man you guys
work hard you're out there you're
tweeting all [ __ ] days yeah out there
insulting people
uh you do the podcast you know hey
listen man you're young this is what
it's for yeah comedy is such a
it's such a spread out thing now you you
do so much yeah if you want to shoot
videos you can do videos you want to do
a podcast you can do a podcast you want
to do a podcast and shoot videos you can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want well
that's the other thing as well because
you know it's so easy to do high quality
stuff now and there's certain guys that
just [ __ ] you know you know that guys
like you i mean like
guys like ari you know
big j the you know those guys that i
look up to that just kind of just you
guys didn't [ __ ] change the way you
talked you didn't change the way you
walk you did what you did you know what
i'm saying i was like [ __ ] it you're
like come to me or don't i'm gonna give
fans i'm gonna do my thing
so that that was very inspirational and
i in turn take that and put it into
things like legion of skanks skank fast
gas digital which is the podcast network
i run and that's kind of the spirit of
you know what i do you know and all the
things with all the projects that i have
it's like you know we celebrate
you know kind of just you know i don't
free speech is a hacky word but it's
like you know we celebrate
you know just kind of saying comedy man
you're trying to be funny funny first
just being [ __ ] funny exactly you
know i don't like drama even comedy but
no it's uh
that's a troubling time for you as a
comedian
and as a human being
you know i said that that's the time in
your life as a performer that you could
become an alcoholic or a coke fiend or
you know a [ __ ] junkie on speed or
heroin because
you come out here you come out here with
a dream i saw it a thousand times
i saw it a thousand times and if you
look at
a lot of comics who did get on
television
there was a lot of issues with rehabs
and stuff like that while they were hot
on tv because a part of you is just
saying [ __ ] and doing [ __ ] there's a
comic you would never do or say
do you know what i'm saying
if they put you tomorrow on abc
they wouldn't some show yeah calls you
up when you're in this show when you're
playing this
sweetheart of a [ __ ] guy
how long could you last on there all day
people yelling at you for using the
wrong word
say this word say it
next take it's
[ __ ] and all of a sudden you know they
come at you again how long do you snap
you know how long as a comedian you know
what the road is like you have all this
freedom on the road
the great eddie griffin once told me
because when you got into comedy you get
into comedy not to have a job
and all of a sudden one day
you have a job yeah
that's very true that's i've never i've
never felt that more than right now
i've never been busier in my life when i
had a [ __ ] day job i mean i would
take off when i'm done with my day job
boom i check out i'll [ __ ] go out do
whatever i wanted to do now there's
freedom of being a comedian too look we
you know i i can't complain it's [ __ ]
it's a brilliant thing and it's amazing
and you know i can never complain about
what i do
um but at the same time the mental
disconnection from a day job where you
can just like literally you live for the
weekend friday hits and you're like go
out with your friends and
with something like this you know where
it's like you do you you're doing your
passion whatever it is for your comedy
what if you're living your passion and
that's your entire career you never turn
it off and that's really mentally
exhausting that never like that never
stops and anybody who excels at anything
like at a really high level you know you
know it's
that obsession i think is like more
exhausting than anything else
well look that first time you go into a
market you know i'm thinking back to 98
when i was already a regular but that
was it
i couldn't bust that
i got put on at the improv
i got put on at the lab factory only on
monday nights for latinos night it was
20 minutes gilbert asked about bless his
soul he's still around i still thank him
because he used to give me every monday
night a 20 [ __ ] minute spot even
though jimmy masada did not want me on
the stage
so that was cool of him you know
but that was it
i would showcase for things [ __ ] you
nobody would ever pick me montreal
cbs showcase
[ __ ] oh you name it you [ __ ] name
it
so for years i went all right now i
gotta figure this out
they're not gonna give it to me so i
gotta go rock their [ __ ] world one
way or another
and i started doing movies i didn't do
movies because i wanted to
i did movies because i knew it would be
it would get me a little closer to my
goal only maybe to the back door that's
where it is and look at the end it was a
[ __ ] podcast
it was our ability to [ __ ] tell
stories on here and bring them to people
that's what really made the push
it wasn't the [ __ ] movies it wasn't
the tv shows i mean it helps
it helps people notice you
but this is what really this medium
really helped a lot of comedians
and it really opened up the door for a
lot of comedians me being very fortunate
well it turned it it made
it's it just it changed the relationship
between comedy fans and comedians
because before it was you go to a comedy
club once twice a year three times a
year you know and that's it and you see
some comedians you love me you think
they're great you buy their album you
watch their special it's a very
disconnected relationship
um but now it's like with the podcast
you know it doesn't even matter if i you
know if i if i'm not even a funny mood
one week
they're with me right there you know
what i'm saying that's a that's a
different thing if you know you if you i
had a [ __ ] kid you listen to me find
out
like on my podcast i mean not literally
on the podcast i don't find out but like
i find out i find out that day
or i i go to have a conversation with my
chick we're gonna have a conversation
after the podcast that i'm really on
edge because you listen to the episode i
wish i could give you the episode number
so if you're actually interested in this
i'll tell you if you tweet me or ask me
on facebook
but um oh no it was the day that me and
dave this dave
louis versus dave is the name of the
episode because i'm really [ __ ] on
edge because my chick was pregnant and
we we're gonna talk about it we're gonna
talk about what we're gonna do with the
baby right after the podcast
so i'm like freaking the [ __ ] out i just
come back from the road a road gig i was
in montreal my buddy neighbor gatzi
and his chick was pregnant and i was
like [ __ ] losing my mind dude and i
really want to keep the baby you know
what i'm saying she was like she's very
measured very smart check
and um
me and dave smith we get into a fight on
the podcast and it's not even about that
we i'm [ __ ] freaking out
and we ended up just blowing up and
getting to a huge thing over nothing
um but it's kind of funny like listen
back to that and it's like these are
like these big moments like that night
i'm fine i'm having a conversation on
whether or not we're gonna keep my son
that's a different type of connection
with the [ __ ] comedian that you got
in 1996. and dane when you're going to
bring it back to what you said about
dane dane kind of understood that you
needed that type of connection with
people he was the first guy to go oh
[ __ ] it's more than just telling jokes
and he was great at telling jokes he was
you know huge and murdering it wasn't
like he was ignoring telling jokes he
was going out writing material and
[ __ ] you know performing at a very
high level but
he was the first guy to go like oh [ __ ]
i can connect with these fans in a
different way and that was kind of the
beginning of social media and podcasting
i think is kind of an extension of that
of that you know podcasting is radio
meets all of that social media [ __ ]
and then we have this [ __ ] and people
[ __ ] they're sitting here with us i
love you see that on that meme i'll pull
that meme up brother listen you'll love
it it's the best meme i've ever seen
about podcasting it's uh it's called
just look look up uh what it's like to
listen to podcasts
oh i think i've seen it yeah i love it
it's great and it's a for the audio
listeners it's a picture um on a wall
and it's girls eating ice cream on a
wall and then there's a kid sitting next
to the picture eating an ice cream cone
not in the you gotta see it i'm probably
not explaining it well for the audio
people but look it up yeah that's it
right there
it's so funny how i always thought i
would be good at radio
like i would go on the road
and they'd make me do radio and i did
really well on the radio
and the people would talk to me and they
go would you consider
uh a radio job and
i leave there all fired up like maybe
i could just move to
north dakota work the comedy club be the
first i'm seeing just work the radio and
just
i didn't even know what they were paying
like i would settle down for that job it
was so funny how
in a way i always knew the radio was
somewhere in my future right but the
radio showed up as a podcast which is
very interesting
i didn't want it to be radio i've never
wanted this to be radio i always wanted
this to be
a pirate type thing i want you to listen
to this
i'd rather just do the audio than the
visual
i do the visual because i'm a handsome
[ __ ] and i want to see what's
cracking like i don't want to rip you
you don't want to rip your fans off and
not give them that yeah no no no
um you know what you don't deprive them
of that mug yeah i wanted people to get
there you know i was always intrigued
when i watched it the 50s how people
would gather around the radio families
would come down at seven o'clock in the
50s listen to the green hornet
you know and we would sit there for for
an hour or 30 minutes [ __ ] silent
they would say maybe saying that that's
what really intrigued me to podcast
that i wanted to get people listening
again
do you know what i'm saying
just listening deep to you like i really
believe that
like i wanted i don't think people were
listening anymore
yeah we listen to music and
but to listen to people talk real talk
yeah like what we do here you know we
talk about you correct
[ __ ] just affecting you right now in
your life that's absolutely correct
that's why i didn't i never even like
talking topical stuff
you know i get emails every day [ __ ] you
you didn't talk about the ufc i'm not
joe rogan
i'm not joe rogan why should i talk
about the [ __ ] ufc like joe you
listen to joe too let joe talk about
that i love not talking it's funny
because everyone thinks because i do a
show at michael bisping i do a podcast
and a radio show
and everyone
when i come onto the show like this or
whoever show i do they think i'm always
going to talk about ufc i love
not talking about ufc because i talk
about it all day i mean i talk about a
few hours a week so it's like you know i
could talk about this [ __ ] all [ __ ]
day who cares you know um i like i like
just having a conversation and see where
it goes even with you but you make that
easy as well because when i do other
shows a lot of times they need a little
bit more structure you know what i'm
saying that's just a testament to how
good you are at kind of having
an ability to tell a story and keep the
conversation going
a lot of shitty podcasts out there
well listen
before i became before i started
podcasting okay what do you
when when did we start podcasting like
2012 september 2012 so i was doing it i
was doing it 2010 with felicia
okay so
10 year 2010 was seven years ago
at that point in my life
i was doing stand-up comedy in 19
[ __ ] years
19 years
that's a [ __ ] veteran okay yeah and a
lot of those 19 years were veteran wars
you know what i'm saying one night is
triple wars
going on stage hungover but learning
control
being on stage and going wow
look at these [ __ ] they're
paying attention to me
you know 10 years ago people would
[ __ ] look away
people would eat people would
talk to each other now
i got everybody's [ __ ] eyeball i'm
doing something right yeah i'm moving
right
you know that comes from being on the
road that don't come from [ __ ]
sitting at your house and telling your
friends
i i headlined the stand last night or
whatever these people do
that comes from banging it the [ __ ] out
you know and uh
i felt when i got on there
yeah we have a lot of gaps i listen to
earlier [ __ ] churches and i want to
jump out of [ __ ] window but
in time you just learn you learn the
timing
you remember stories from your life it's
almost like with santa like how they say
you have to like listen to your standup
sets over and over again
um i listen to the podcasts back all the
time it used to be because i would edit
them because i used to edit my own [ __ ]
i was producing my own [ __ ] before we
had you know studio and all this other
stuff
but
that's how i think i got really good at
podcasting because i was editing right
you listen i was i had to i listened to
and and not only that we were like we
had bad audio so i would really have to
listen through and listen to things over
and over again you find your little tics
the things that are [ __ ] annoying and
the things that don't sound good you
know your mic diction how far you stay
away people don't get like people that
are pros you know what i'm saying like
we literally think about right at least
i do we think about all that [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] you know all that when i leave
here as high as i am stupid i'll sit on
the couch and think about the podcast
and the points that we made the points
that we didn't make
and how i should call lee and we'll do
the podcast over again and include that
point and i'm like [ __ ] that noise
at least home in bed it's 5 15 the
[ __ ] morning i'm going to call leon
gold without retaping but you know 5 15.
let me tell you something guys
i was with her today i called for
felicia today i gave a big it was great
to see it i talked to him on the phone
twice a week when i was doing the
podcast with felicia felicia was editing
it
and i couldn't listen to the whole thing
because it wasn't my dream
i wanted to give it to you how it was
done
i did not want to [ __ ] around
if you call me tomorrow joey
listen
the thing i said about the chinese chick
eating my ass so i gotta take it out
you're dead louie is that i ain't
thinking brother i had to do that
recently for somebody yeah
i took it out i took it out recently
somebody i can't do it because this i
want you to behave yourself i want you
to come on here and i want the word to
get out
i want you to go [ __ ] joey diaz
i told the story of [ __ ] my ex-wife
from the eyeball he [ __ ] up and that's
all i cannot well i've had three people
calling me and i have not cut their [ __ ]
and two of them i don't think i don't
even know if they're around anymore they
won't i refuse can i tell you why i did
it
because
here's i do here's what i do right
number one i almost feel like it's like
a it's a rule like if i can i would
right
your live show has a lot of people
watching it there's how i mean however
many thousands of people watching this
live right
my live show is behind a paywall that's
the only way to watch my show live the
podcast is free
but in order to watch the video in order
to watch it live you got to go to the
website um and it's a much smaller
fraction of people
you can't get rid of something that goes
out on your feed really you can't once
it's out there on youtube for free boom
that's it
for me you know legion of skanks is
there's probably you know a couple
thousand that watch it live so that's a
little bit harder but for like real last
podcast or some of the other shows
which that that's what it was it was my
smaller show there was you know a couple
hundred people watching live wasn't a
big deal i was like find it i'll do it
but it's annoying i almost feel like you
should
it
if i guess if i would have said no he
would have been fine but i'll tell you
right now i'm i'm probably not gonna
have him back on the show no no no no no
no no you made me do more work yeah you
can't you can't trust me nothing wrong
lee
we've said some [ __ ] up stories
i've said some [ __ ] up stories of
course so if i've said
300 stories on here
don't you think i have a hundred
so i can't [ __ ] repeat
how many times have i sat here with you
at night like well these microphones
ain't on i gotta tell you about
something or a person or something that
happened years ago and you'll sit there
and say why didn't you even tell me
about this
because you know you can't say every i
got a thousand stories i can't tell i'm
here
are you [ __ ] crazy oh you're glowing
i'm really high
like there's like a
this is tremendous yeah it's really good
it's nice no no i love it this is this
is i'm i'm going to
murder tonight it's going to be the best
show i've ever had in my entire life
i'm going up to the laugh factory i'm
brian bradband's show i'm going to
change the world you want to take some
stars to go from yeah maybe midnight
hour i'm going to take one more right
now so i hit 2000 on the show oh [ __ ]
yeah i hope you're watching this ladies
and gentlemen lisa
how many
are we sure do we agree that you want to
do
three thousand give me a small one don't
tell me no
i don't have no food in case you start
trembling and [ __ ] oh i'm trembling
right now so let's see what happens oh
there's brownies there's chocolate
brownies yeah sure that's e8 that's good
that's 2 000's good i did 850 or 8 25
last time
there we go it's a record right there
just christ joey lee cyan has broken
the [ __ ]
[Music]
here's what i'm talking about ladies and
gentlemen it's pretty incredible
he got his stripes back the ones he
loves
you're playing the death song though no
no no no no
yeah
when they open me up they'll be like why
is he why are his insides purple
the other night he i kept telling him
louis gomez is coming wednesday night
going to training
like friday night he ate like 600. yeah
he lied to me he played boy he was
cheating chung on the phone
saturday night he ate like eight stars
sunday he went sabbatical and then
monday he tried to come in here and cut
me short
and i told him listen if i was you i'd
eat every [ __ ] star in that bag
because louie gomez is coming downtown
it's like santa claus
and he ain't [ __ ] around wednesday
night he kept then last night he did
light training he did sixteen hundred
look at them oh yeah
this is it tonight lisa yeah are they
down are you are they in already no one
is
that's 2800 ladies and gentlemen
oh my god do you think does the average
person is it this hard for the average
person or is it just this hard for lee
it hasn't well my body's trying to tell
me like stop doing this but it's it's uh
i hope you have a little heart don't put
a paddle jesus christ
i can't believe you want to do three
thousand milligrams
you can't take the applause back that's
really true but that's the pause back
that'd be like good i have to end my
friendship with you might have to murder
me right
i don't know how to make that right in
the world if you applaud her that'd be
like [ __ ] editing
yeah that's crazy
it's gonna be only two seconds oh my god
i had anxiety i don't know
[ __ ] like that
um
that [ __ ] food [ __ ] me up today
something else is going on i don't know
last week i took that i took a five day
body bomb
to clean out all the fungi in my body i
had these weird rashes and
from the years sleeping on [ __ ]
mattresses and [ __ ]
but i had this rash that you would flare
up from time to time oh my god like
sometime one day i went into my army it
was like a [ __ ] red thing like
somebody whipped me um i was like i
gotta stop this i went to the doctor
he goes that's like 18 years of being
out there yeah that's all i've been
doing comedy dog that's a lot of fungus
the one fungi toenail disappeared the
new vanilla was growing up
but the other one's still in the valley
of death
there you go ladies and gentlemen these
are [ __ ] monsters these are [ __ ]
monsters i'm set by i'm such a
hypochondriac like i hate
i hate going to the doctor i hate like
oh
i mean i'd go like uh i had to get
surgery i had a sty
that was recovering and we came back and
it became like a cyst that had to be
removed so they had to do like a
physical and all that [ __ ] but that was
like oh i hate it
you know you're so afraid of like death
35 yeah 35. you know what man if you
have insurance you have to go to the
doctor you know what they charged me at
st joe's hospital and they didn't shut
cut my tongue this is why
my whole no do what you want brother my
discomfort
with everything is i think of
the american family i think of lisa and
his brother growing up i really do i
think of that's the american family two
two kids
you your wife and two kids the girl and
the little boy
okay i don't know what you make for a
living i know what your wife makes for a
living could you afford to go to the
yankee game once a week with your two
kids how much is yanking him a [ __ ]
lie for a family of four when you're
making 500 hours a week driving the
truck in the bronx
200 with overtime your rent what could
your rent be
you live in the [ __ ] bronx somewhere
or brooklyn right you know here put it
in here
clean it with this oh yeah perfect uh
you know what can your rent be i'm
talking about the
the medium range american family
how much can they possibly remember what
can they take your child can you take
your child to the next game
can you take your wife and get popcorn
and hot dogs and [ __ ] like that no they
they do but they get no you can't but
they rack up credit card debt what if
you want to come out here and visit
disneyland
right bring four people at 450. most
people can't afford that no that's what
i'm saying to you and this is
what pisses me
the [ __ ] off please stop breathing heavy
please
you're making me nervous you you look
like me before i give blood there's
nothing to breathe heavy about now i
know how stupid i look are you afraid to
get blood oh hold on we're doing people
let me don't get me started my point cuz
i almost i fainted on the show two weeks
ago why because i bit my tongue and i
told the story on the show and i fainted
from just telling the story all right
but let me tell you what happened sorry
guys so the other night i caught my i
bite my tongue
at two in the afternoon he's got the
last one let's go lee come on lee while
we're ready
bro
i went to the hospital
i got there at 11 o'clock at night
i got there a quarter to 11
and they [ __ ] uh look at look at look
at this look what i gotta deal with he's
holding his own mouth
this is what i gotta do anyway
i go to the hospital 11 o'clock
i tell them listen
this is bleeding they don't offer me a
gauze they don't offer me nothing
this is bleeding uncontrollably i'm
going to the bathroom pulling out paper
towels
putting them under my [ __ ] thing
next thing you know they call me back
there
they ask me a bunch of creepy questions
i give them the insurance card then they
send me back out there
and at 12 30 they come get me and they
go listen we made a thing
we can't staple it but there's a doctor
who's coming at three and he'll take
care of it go over there and sit tight
till three o'clock wait what time is it
it's [ __ ] 11 o'clock at night 11 30
or 12. i'm sitting and i got to be on
the plane the next day for utah
i'm like what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
sorry you know what i'm not [ __ ]
sitting here i'll go home jesus christ i
bled the whole [ __ ] night guy i got
the next morning my mask is filled with
blood to sleep it was terrible
i flew to utah
you didn't go to the doctor huh you can
go back to the doctor i went to the
doctor in utah oh you're telling the
story okay i went to the urgent care i
went in there they took my blood press
they talked very nicely to me they took
me in the back a young doctor came i
can't stitch you because then you can't
tell jokes
i go what do you want to do because
let's try something we took a piece of
uh
this glue this cocaine thing that
shortens the nerves and the pores so you
stop the bleeding a little bit then he
put a piece of like metal
in my tongue and he goes i'll fall out
of his own little just stop the bleeding
boom healed
they took my insurance card
the other hospital sent me home three
hours you ready for this ladies and
gentlemen
you know how much st jones and burbank
charged me that hospital
396 dollars to send me home
you know how much the other place and
utah charged me how much
why
because the they took it out of my
[ __ ] copay or some [ __ ]
that's how that's how you human beings
are bro yeah this place didn't even do
nothing they were like you have to wait
here i could see if they've gained the
ice
i could see if they [ __ ] sat me down
or put me in the back on the observation
they never said listen you're losing a
lot of [ __ ] blood
why don't you go in the back and let's
lay you down let's watch you for a
little while they never said that you
bro if you saw me you could see the
blood all over my face all over my hands
this wasn't no [ __ ] general man
but anyway who gives a [ __ ] i'm just
thinking about people who
you know what you got to do somebody
told me this my friend my friend katie
did this if you need anything just go to
the go to the emergency room go to the
hospital and they have to treat you
i know that give a fake name yeah you
can't give a fake tell me your big [ __ ]
no not today because they have cameras
there
and they no it's not like the old days
in new york city what's your name john
labonte i think you can get away with it
i really do
are we taking over lee no no no no i'm
just getting some
how nice whatever we'll do
wait it's a little delicious
yes sir let's do some more [ __ ] stars
leo don't be a [ __ ]
set a new record that joey can't beat so
my question for you lewis yes is how are
you gonna combat uh gaining weight back
okay because that like i just because i
just ate forty thousand uh grams of
sugar no no no no we're the source of
death not just a night because you lost
weight because i i've gone up and down
my entire life and i went down and i've
recently gained 15 pounds so i have to
go back down i [ __ ] fluctuate man
it's it's a nightmare it's really a
nightmare i was on bert's podcast
talking to him about this but it's like
it becomes an obsession and that's the
problem i almost wish i just was fat and
never even thought about it and just
[ __ ] live my life as a fat guy and
die eight years sooner than i would die
if i was in shape
because now i just think about it all
the time so
do i have advice for you no i i don't i
mean i have no advice because i will
probably be fat again one day
so you see you just the minute you just
admit that there's going to be cycles
that's for me it's very difficult i
personally have a thing where
it's about work is it because i'm a
comedian
like it's about gratification so when my
friends are telling me oh bro you look
good you lost weight that that's great
chicks are coming up to me like oh you
look really good she lost all this
weight but as soon as the gratification
disappears and as soon as people stop
talking about it
it's that comedian thing in me that i i
look for something else i'll start doing
something else you know what i'm saying
you see he was asking me about like
losing weight and get gaining weight
that's what happens i'll lose weight and
then people stop congratulating me for
it and then it stops being as important
as it's not as much of a priority
because i'm a [ __ ] narcissist
so then i gain weight again and then i
go back and then i lose weight again and
then they come back oh you look great
but it disappears after a few months
so it's [ __ ] up
anything you think about all night when
you're on these [ __ ]
stars you gotta think about losing
weight not eating you're gonna sit there
like i just hate them how many [ __ ]
grams of sugar are in these stores
they're seven calories per person what
about the grams of sugar two no i'm
telling you that yeah
free impossible this is diet
diabetic free no way [ __ ] sugar free
this is two grams of sugar per star no
free actually it might be they're pretty
small yeah no no no no why would i
[ __ ] blow smoke i mean i am eating
hold on if i just had 10 of them that's
20 grams of sugar it's not great joey
what are you gonna do you gotta live
from time to time
you're puerto rican right that's in your
blood what do you think you drink all
day [ __ ] sugarcane juice
your [ __ ] cousins are drinking
sugarcane juice you know what i'm saying
that you wouldn't
they don't need it i'm telling you it's
two grams don't worry about nothing i
got you
i got you two making that number up
though no the what
making them no google i don't [ __ ]
know nothing you google it see how many
not gonna [ __ ] tell you there's
nothing to google these are my people
they don't tell you nothing they only
tell me
if you want tomorrow
awesome how many grams of sugar
yeah there's two that's the 80s yeah
there's two don't
[Laughter]
is
whatever they need i make it up you tell
them whatever i'm dying better can i eat
these eat ten of them take a chance
what are you gonna do
when you're in the ambulance like
carlito's way [ __ ]
if you die from candies it can be weird
that is the most hilarious way to die
listen dog if you thought this thought i
could see myself
really having a bad that's why whenever
i [ __ ] take these i be careful lately
because these things will put you into
big time anxiety attack like this so
this could catch up with you louis gomez
this ain't no joke
oh listen i'm just gonna get you later
on like late at night also that's the
last time look at look at zombo over
there he's ready to go he's done it what
does it mean when you taste seaweed that
means that you're going down dogs you're
drowning
last time do a bong it we'll take that
yeah come on baby i'm done
it's done the last time after i i had
825 milligrams which was way less than
i've had today okay and i'm still
standing here joey no you're the man i'm
gonna do the best [ __ ] i've ever done
i'm gonna i'm just i'm doing all i'm
doing i'm gonna [ __ ] improv every
joke tonight it's over
i'm happy for you i'm ditching the old
jokes you'll be calling me later going
what the [ __ ] did you give me i [ __ ]
ate a bag of dicks i forgot everything
i'm doing louis ck's act [ __ ] it i'm
just going up and doing [ __ ]
um no no i last time when i went to
sleep that night
i heard like little whispers like if you
tripped on mushrooms like you at the end
of the night after you've come down you
go to sleep it was almost like that type
of thing
and that's what i'm getting now it's
like when i'm not looking directly if i
look directly at you i'm good right i
love the whispers
yeah it's good they tell you they tell
you things you don't know i love it i
love it i love it joey you're the
[ __ ] man
don't listen to him he's a [ __ ] no [ __ ]
you i can stay up if i want to i don't
have to be a class till 9 20.
oh my god
i uh
get like i my anxiety with edibles is
that lift
that lift off especially when you eat a
lot of them
that's why i always tell like lee's used
to a thousand of them real quick and
then another thousand yeah and then we
just pick it apart little by little at
the at the core like like uh you know
but you you don't need these so i
wouldn't want you to go from a to z and
then
there you are breathing in your heart a
[ __ ] red band called an ambulance i
know i hear a thousand stories that
happen
that's crazy though
the last thing i would want is for
anybody who left here for them to have
to call an ambulance because they're
heartbroken
listen if i call an ambulance i'm giving
them a fake name
that's all i know they're not getting my
real [ __ ] name but i'm not paying for
[ __ ] first of all they'll fingerprint
you by your
then they'll do an ncic and they get the
picture you from mexico
via puerto rico playing bongos and [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no no you got to give them
everything now it's not a joke anymore i
think you can get away with it i really
feel like it used to you told me that i
couldn't jerk off in airplane bathrooms
the first time i was on this show
i still do it every every time
disgusting no not a cross-country flight
joey i'm not building up six hours of
just you know what you do bro you sit
there and you put the blanket on your
and you look around the people right you
make eye contact with the stewardess but
no you you whack off this way with your
fingers you're gonna end up like there's
like the sex offender
no
i used to be young laser transfer blow
and i'd be up all night that's basically
in public isn't it and then no it's not
in public it's under the blanket
i'm scratching a [ __ ] itch it's
[ __ ] skylar nobody you know but
sometimes they sit there and watch it
they love it you're like banging that
yuko the dude that security guard just
went to jail for that which guy from the
from the football game remember he was
obviously
he was like obviously jacking his dick
and looking at the um the cheerleaders
you put a blanket on that's old school
is that you know what i notice here that
homeless people are extremely animated
like way more animated than new york new
york they're more dangerous seeming no
they're both pretty dangerous but
they're very they're like they like you
know they do the bugs bunny movement
here like the you know
that thing
and in new york it's way way more public
masturbation i haven't seen any homeless
people masturbating in public here and
in new york city they're jerking off i
mean a lot a lot they are you know this
show thank you because next time i bring
a rain jacket i'm a [ __ ] people jerk
listen the homeless scene here
last night
the weirdest thing happened i gotta meet
my agents they're young kids
they dress nice they got nice hair
i parked my car
i walked towards them
and it's then them two kids to the 24
and this black kid
i'm thinking another kid had like the
red wrapper jacket and a hat and
i thought it was jewelry i don't [ __ ]
know you know
i'm like maybe they represent him
as i get there
they're [ __ ] talking
and so i didn't know nothing i i turned
around and introduced how you doing nice
to meet you i give my agents a hug and
we all walk in
and next you know the dude's behind me
and he's like man what are you gonna eat
i'll tell you what i want
i
you're telling me what you want
what are you talking about and he's like
come on man let me eat with you
[ __ ] you're a director of [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm no [ __ ] director
he's like come on man he goes come on
let me which i even pay for half of it
bro i could smell the alcohol
you could smell the [ __ ] you know it was
just sad you know i would have gave him
the [ __ ] chicken
then the waitress drove out
yeah the waitress says he's been
bothering people i don't know who's
homeless or whatever anymore i can't
tell
those [ __ ] 7-elevens they're out
there today i gave a chicken dollar
i got the i took the the doll out of the
car and i gave it to this woman today
you know you don't know what the [ __ ]
they do i have difficulties
i have difficulty too
but from time to time you got to be soft
it could be jesus in l.a
yes fine l.a i'll give it to you you
should be more generous you're right i
agree but in new york city
you're walking to the subway if you're
going to be generous i mean you're going
to [ __ ] you will have no money no
it's expensive you heard what i said i
said i racially
profile profile so no blacks i do no no
i didn't say that no no he was a black
woman who i gave them okay no black man
you have a better chance if you're a
woman getting money out of me 100
percent got a young girl 100 oh my god
i don't i just look at them better if
there's no limbs i'm ashamed of them if
you have no no no they got limbs i'll
throw them in a small nickel if they
have no limbs
you ever have zero
you have one limb you better get the
[ __ ] out of my face you got a cup next
to me and there's no i throw a nickel
you're a good guy you're missing a
[ __ ] body part i'm all in and the
cuban side
but you get these [ __ ] people you
know i know who's faking my mom had a
bar that the guy used to play deaf
yeah of course you know the new york
that's big where they can you see the
gypsies that have they [ __ ] had
babies they drug up the babies oh my god
that's crazy
no no i've seen all that [ __ ] and 10 out
of 10 i don't stop
i don't stop yeah listen sir come here
look look at that
i got to go we can actually go out in
front of a 7-eleven with lee right now
and just pretend that he's
our baby
he was all drugged up make some money
guys please help us our baby's dying at
least fine don't get him follow up he's
all right because when you leave he'll
put his head back
and he'll start looking around like
zombo
and he'll keep thinking how his heart's
beating fast then he'll play games
himself and tomorrow morning when i call
him he'll tell me his story how he drove
himself and got a heart test because his
heart was beating out of his chest again
no no leave him alone please don't take
him nowhere he's going to be fine when
we leave here he's going to call
domino's he's right
he's going to get two pizzas
two orders of wings domino's pizza is
better than the average like pizza here
right i don't [ __ ] know it because
you guess what i do when i go on the
road i'll order domino's pizza before
i'll just take my chance at pizza in
whatever city it is or it's in
i don't think my chances are dominoes
you're from [ __ ] new york yeah no
[ __ ] no i don't
you don't understand my point of view
you gotta have a stand yeah everybody
represents the hook represent your hood
i don't need dominoes that's it i'd
rather die than eat [ __ ] dominoes i
don't eat dominoes
no not acceptable you're on the road no
no no
two o'clock in the morning you're
starving listen
i live here and i hold that six seven
months if i can do it
you can do it i don't eat pizza until i
get to gotham down the corner yeah i
hold that though i'm a soldier where do
you eat pizza in new york the place down
the corner from gotham i just told you
right down the front where what place is
that i don't know anything you know me i
don't know names
i just know i get it
i get out i make a left i walk 40 yards
and i zip in there they got tremendous
cheese pizza stromboli's i eat pizza on
the jersey side and that's it when i
come back
now because of the baby we go to laurel
canyon which ain't bad i mean don't go
in there going jesus christ no no no
take your chances the other day he made
a nice sausage no you ain't made a nice
sausage garlic slice
very nice he gave it to me in the house
what am i gonna do i had to bite into it
show him i had a gratitude i'm not a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i went to the pick
up pizza for my daughter and he goes hey
take the slice try it it's pretty
[ __ ] good yeah is your daughter doing
jiu jitsu no
she doesn't understand that concept it
would just be like throwing away
money for how to jump up and down that's
i'm thinking jesus christ i'm about to
put my son in jiu jitsu joey they they
don't comprehend it unless yeah but we
know what they do my understanding i
i've talked about it takes time it takes
i know you had mickey on the show is
[ __ ] hilarious we have this this is
this is birdbank that's tmz they're
looking for they're looking for somebody
they know lee hit the 3000 mark and
they're looking for leaving lee you're a
star baby lee you're a star dog
congratulations
[ __ ] everybody you busted my plane
i don't know who to think you thank
[ __ ] star one for making it possible
for you to work yourself into a
a lean meeting
marijuana eating machine you think star
one then you thank the jew god for
giving you life
for protecting you every day then you
thank your beautiful fiancee paula no
for giving you the power in the world
then you thank your partner in crime
uncle joey diaz who got me started on my
path to being the [ __ ] jew monster
that i am
they call me anti-holocaust they you're
a [ __ ] animal you understand me
that's what i'm talking about lisa
anyway where you gonna be next
soon you're here this weekend where you
performing yeah yeah i'm here uh
if you're if you're watching live i mean
nothing you can't come tonight but
tomorrow night i'll be at the laugh
factory i'm going to be also at a haha
comedy club
yeah and then also friday night i got
two shows at the heart walk for the
[ __ ] huh oh really all right sweetie
did sadly let you up here no no i leave
saturday morning which i wish i could
say more i [ __ ] like every time
every time i [ __ ] come to l.a now i'm
gonna bring my son next time i come i
think i'm gonna bring my son and just
because i'm doing airbnb which is the
[ __ ] can't put your kid in there being b
no i'm going to babysit her then i'll go
to there you get rashes and [ __ ] now you
don't want to jesus christ or get hurt
either way i'll get a hotel it's just i
don't know how listen i was thinking
about what you do when i commended and
it's really weird how
you uh and that you and a lot of other
people i i i got three days
i got three days
i i don't know how you do a week
i would die i usually no i don't do that
on the road la i do a week
because i come you know two three times
a year i want to come out and i you know
oh my god i'm not even here the other
thing is like i make friends la is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] first of all people that
[ __ ] in l.a they're crazy they're crazy
they're crazy la comics are the [ __ ]
coolest people you guys are all [ __ ]
super welcoming and just like you know i
mean sir some of my favorite people in
the world live out here and i make more
friends every time i come out so it's
like i can't come out for a few days i
want to come out and like do spa times
no you're right no no no no i just said
i can't you know yeah i would stand here
for ten days if you could but you miss
your kid yeah that's that's the hard
part you know
you're just [ __ ] around so it's kind
of weird man
i just got a new bed i gave up my king
size for a [ __ ] queen size you gotta
do what you're gonna need for space
brother i needed the space look at lee
he gave us the bedroom for the couch
what are you gonna do these are [ __ ]
that no
especially tonight he's on the couch he
goes home falls asleep on the couch she
comes out at six in the morning goes
where the [ __ ] you bentley
like i said next thursday
we're at the [ __ ] ice house
workout night that's it i'm just trying
to put together a decent hour guys i
can't do these [ __ ] old jokes no more
come on out 10 bucks have some wings
whatever the [ __ ] you want to eat then
the week after that i'm a brayer improv
a dynamic place you understand me
one of the original originators that's
why i used to do my uh once a month
the second
wednesday of the month i started there
like in 2009 so
it always feels like [ __ ] going home
i want to thank number one i told you in
the beginning of the podcast
hello tushie is back you're sitting
there going joey what the [ __ ] is hello
tushy hello tushy is a portable bidet
that you
latch onto your toilet seat
and you sit on it
you pee and then you turn this on water
sprinkles into your anus
and your little
private parts
and it washes nice and clean
you wipe it down with a little portable
[ __ ] thing they also supply towels
you're saying joy why do i need a bidet
why
because 9 out of 10 you're a filthy [ __ ]
number two let's not talk about you
let's not get personal here
hold on one second the [ __ ] marines
are flying by again it's 9 30 at night i
need this [ __ ] someone got me the blue
angels joey thank you for having me
[ __ ]
flying over me what i'm trying to tell
you is this
he only at dad's house this weekend he's
going to be talking to you about
insurance his time in the military
he's going to talk to you about his weak
what happened while he's walking around
just glance over his [ __ ] ask
yourself
what does my father's [ __ ] smell like
well i
if he was
listen i'm not saying your father's
[ __ ] stinks
i'm just asking yourself to look at
everybody
and ask yourself what my father's asked
miss mele he eats sausage you know he
does so many things that are wrong
anyway
why take the chance why live and doubt
with the [ __ ] your dad's [ __ ]
stink
get him a portable [ __ ]
bidet for father's day how's that for
you boom boom boom you set it up for you
let me tell you something but days are
the way to go no toilet paper you save
on trees you got a 90-day guarantee i
mean bidets are the way they go i know
people who bought four of them you put
them in every [ __ ] bathroom in your
house you understand me you know why
because none of the ten is gonna become
your new thinking tank when you got
nothing to do you can't take the
pressures of life
you're gonna go in the bathroom
you're gonna turn the water on you're
gonna sit there you're gonna sit there
like a doctor you're gonna spread your
legs your ass is gonna drop into the
[ __ ] toilet and you're gonna have
sprinkling water hitting your ass listen
listen there's nothing more meditative
than that you could take 19 foot like
that dude they got the united settlement
they beat up dunk king
what's the chinese guy's name got beat
up on united flight doctor he got an
uncle settlement he's in hong kong right
now dr wang is in hong kong right now
as we speak he's getting a foot rub
he's got a thong on he's got little
chinese chicks just going like this to
his shoulders and just giving him little
karate chops
he's smoking [ __ ] opium he's living
like a doctor joey what's your point i
have no idea my point is down hello
tushy.com [ __ ] that's my point
whether it's your father your mother
your grandmother's [ __ ] stinks
somebody in your family needs a portable
bidet in the house and this is your take
this is your chance to get this [ __ ]
bidet go to hellotushy.com take a look
at the beautiful bidet they've designed
go on there and press in church bam on
the way out and get 10 percent
delivered to your house who's better
than you you're going to feel confident
you're not going to have [ __ ] skank
ass no more
you're going to be able to go out and
let people sniff your [ __ ] when
you're in a bar you ever been in a bar
and somebody offers to sniff your ass oh
and it's like a game of jeopardy you're
sitting there confused babe it's you
don't know if you're wiped you don't
know if you're scratched no more
no more
before you leave you're still on your
hello tushy while it sprinkles your anus
out of [ __ ] all the fungus and
everything that can grow in there
bam you're meditating you're getting
your thoughts together and you're out
for the night you understand me and
listen if you're gay we're gay friendly
we don't [ __ ] around here hellotushy.com
go to the box on the checkout and press
in church boom
c-h-u-r-c-h and get ten dollars
delivered to your house i love you
[ __ ] see you monday or sunday we
haven't made up our mind once again
hellotushy.com
and i also want to thank honey the best
supplements out there in the market
they're really going to help you out
alpha brand if you don't like it you
gotta you get your money back and we
don't even want the [ __ ] product
who's better than us again i want to
thank honor.com
church and i want to thank
hellotoyshe.com
church have a great weekend thank you
louis gomez thank you lisa thank you
congratulations for breaking the record
all right thank you i i think thank you
to everyone all right all right turn the
[ __ ] thing off will you
why you gotta bother me for now you're
gonna be a man i wanna send you one of
the academy awards
where's the music actually
where's
oh [ __ ] thank you for listening top
suckers
congratulations we love you buddy
you